the following is a conversation with
luiz and joao batala
brothers and co-founders of firma's
library which is an incredible platform
for annotating papers as they write on
the formats library website justice
pierre de fermat scribbled his famous
last theorem in the margins professional
scientists academics and citizen
scientists can annotate equations
figures ideas and write in the margins
for mars library is also a really good
twitter account to follow i highly
recommend it they post little visual
factoids and explorations that reveal
the beauty of mathematics
i love it
quick mention of our sponsors
skiff
simply safe indeed netsuite and for
sigmatic check them out in the
description to support this podcast as a
side note let me say a few words about
the dissemination of scientific ideas
i believe that all scientific articles
should be freely accessible to the
public
they currently are not
in one analysis i saw more than 70 of
published research articles are behind a
paywall
in case you don't know the funders of
the research whether that's government
or industry
aren't the ones putting up the paywall
the journals are the ones putting up the
paywall while using unpaid labor from
researchers for the peer review process
where is all that money from the paywall
going
in this digital age the costs here
should be minimal
this cost can easily be covered through
donation advertisement or public funding
of science
the benefit versus the cost of all
papers being free to read is obvious and
the fact that they're not free goes
against everything science should stand
for which is the free dissemination of
ideas that educate and inspire
science cannot be a gated institution
the more people can freely learn and
collaborate on ideas the more problems
we can solve in the world together and
the faster we can drive old ideas out
and bring new
better ideas in
science is beautiful and powerful and
its dissemination in this digital age
should be free
this is the lex friedman podcast and
here's my conversation with luiz and
joao batala
luis you suggested an interesting idea
imagine if most papers had a
backstory section the same way that they
have an abstract
so
knowing more about how the authors ended
up working on a paper can be extremely
insightful and then you went on to give
a backstory for the feynman qed paper
this is all in a tweet by the way we're
doing tweet analysis today
how much of the human backstory do you
think is important in understanding
the idea itself that's presented in the
paper or in general
i think this gives way more context to
the work of of scientists i think people
a lot of people have this almost kind of
romantic misconception that
the way a lot of scientists work is
almost as the sum of eureka moments
where all of a sudden they sit down and
start writing two papers in a row and
the papers are usually isolated and when
you actually look at it it's the papers
are you know chapters of a way more
complex uh story
and the definement qed paper is a good
example so feynman was actually going
through a pretty dark phase before
writing that paper it was he lost
enthusiasm with physics and doing
physics problems and there was one time
when he was in the cafeteria of cornell
and he saw a guy that was throwing
flights in the air and he noticed that
there was when the plate was in the air
there were two movements there the plate
was wobbling but he also noticed that
the the cornell symbol was rotating and
he was able to figure out the equations
of motions uh the equations of motions
of those uh plates and that uh led him
to kind of think a little bit about
electron orbits in relativity which led
to the paper of
about quantum electrodynamics so that
kind of reignited
his interest in physics and and and
ended up publishing the paper that led
to the his nobel prize basically and i
think it's it's
there are a lot of really interesting
backstories about papers that readers
never get to know friends we did a
couple of months ago um
an ama around a paper a pretty famous
paper the gans paper with ian goodfellow
and so we did an ama where everyone was
could ask questions about the paper and
ian was responding to those questions
you also he was also telling the story
of how he got the idea for that paper in
a bar so there was also an interesting
and a back story i also read a book by
cedric villani
uh these cedric velani is this
mathematician the fields medalist and in
his book he tries to explain how he got
from like
a phd student to the fields metal and he
tries to be as descriptive as possible
every single step how we got to the
fields metal and it's interesting also
to see just the amount of random
interactions and discussions with other
researchers sometimes over coffee and
how it led to like
fundamental breakthroughs and some of
his most important papers so i think
it's super interesting to have that
context of of the backstory well the ian
goodfellow story is kind of interesting
and perhaps that's true for feynman as
well i don't know if it's romanticizing
the thing but
it seems like just
a few little insights and a little bit
of work
does most of the leap required
do you have a sense that for a lot of
the stuff you've looked at
just looking back through history
uh it it wasn't necessarily the grind
of like andrew wiles of the females last
theorem for example
it was more like a a brilliant moment of
insight in fact ian goodfellow has a
kind of sadness to him almost in that
at that time in machine learning like at
that time especially in uh
for gans
you could
code something up really quickly on a
single machine
and almost do the invention go from idea
to uh experimental validation and like a
single night a single person could do it
and now there's kind of a sadness that a
lot of the breakthroughs you might have
in machine learning kind of require
large-scale experiments
so it was almost like the early days
so i wonder how many
low-hanging fruit there are in science
and mathematics
and even engineering where it's like
you could do that little experiment
quickly like you have an insight and a
bar why is it always a bar but you have
an insight at a bar and then just
implement
and the world changes
it's it's a good point i think it also
depends a lot on the maturity of the
field when you look at a field like
mathematics like it's a pretty mature
field uh feels like machine learning um
it's it's growing pretty fast
and um it's actually pretty pretty
interesting i i looked up like the
number of
new papers
on archive with the keyword machine
learning and like 50 of those papers
have been published on in the last 12
months so you can see just the same zero
five zero fifty percent so you can see
the the the the magnitude of growth in
that field and so i think like as fields
mature like those types of moments i
think naturally
uh are less frequent um
it's just a consequence of
that the other point that is interesting
about the backstory is that it can
really make it more memorable in a way
and and by making it more memorable it's
it kind of sediments the knowledge more
in your mind i remember also reading the
sort of the backstory to
to dijkstra's shortest path algorithm
right where he came up with it uh
essentially while he was
sitting down at a at a coffee shop in
amsterdam and he and he came up with
that algorithm over 20 minutes and one
interesting aspect is he didn't have any
pen or paper at the time and so he had
to do it all in his mind and so
there's only so much complexity that you
can handle if you're just thinking about
it in your mind and that like when you
think about the simplicity of dijkstra's
shortest path finding algorithm it's you
know knowing that backstory helps
sediment that algorithm in your mind so
that you don't forget about it as easily
it might be from you that i saw
a meme about texture
it's like he's trying to solve it he
comes up with some kind of random path
and then it's like my parents aren't
home and then he does uh
he figures out the algorithm for the
shortest path
i strike through words to convey memes
but that's hilarious i don't know if
it's in post that we construct stories
that romanticize it apparently with
newton there was no apple
especially when you're working on
problems that have a physical
manifestation or a visual manifestation
it feels like the world
could be an inspiration to you
so it doesn't have to be completely in
on paper
like you could be sitting at a bar and
all of a sudden see something and a
pattern will
will spark another pattern and you can
visualize it and rethink a problem in a
particular way
of course you can also load the math
that you have on paper and always carry
that with you so when you show up to the
bar some little inspiration could be the
thing that changes it is there any other
people
almost on the human side whether it's
physics with feynman
derock einstein or computer science
touring anybody else any backstories
that you remember that jump out
because i'm also referring to
not necessarily these stories where
something magical happens
but these are personalities they have
big egos some of them are super friendly
some of them are like self-obsessed some
of them have anger issues some of them
how do i describe feynman but he appears
to uh
have a
appreciation of the beautiful in all its
forms it has a wit and a cleverness and
a humor about him so it does that come
into play in terms of the construction
of the science
well i think you brought up newton
newton is it's a good example also to
think about his backstory because you
know there's a certain backstory of
newton that people always talk about but
then there's a whole
another aspect of him
that is also a big part of the person
that he was but you know he was really
into alchemy right and that he spent a
lot of time
thinking about that and writing about it
and he took it very seriously he was
really into bible interpretation and
trying to predict things based on the
bible and so there's also a whole
backstory then and of course you need to
look at it in the context that and the
time that when newton lived um but a but
it adds to his personality and it's
important to also understand those
aspects then maybe
you know uh i'm not people people are
not as proud to teach to little kids
but it's important it was part of who he
was and and maybe without those he who
knows what he would have done otherwise
so
well the the cool thing about alchemy
i don't know how it was viewed at the
time
but it almost like to me symbolizes
dreaming of the impossible
like most of the breakthrough ideas kind
of seem impossible until they're
actually done it's like achieving human
flight it's not completely obvious to me
that alchemy is impossible or like
putting myself in the mindset of the
time
and perhaps even still
every everything that uh
you know some of the most incredible
breakthroughs are
would seem impossible
and i wonder the value of
believing
almost like focusing and dreaming of the
impossible such that it is actually is
possible in your mind and that in itself
manifests
whether the accomplishing that goal or
making progress in some unexpected
direction so alchemy almost symbolizes
that for me i distinctly remember having
the same thought of thinking you know
when i learned about atoms and that they
have protons and electrons i was like
okay to make gold you just take whatever
has an atomic weight below it and then
shove another proton in there and then
you have a bunch of gold so like why
don't people do that
it seemed like conceptually is like you
know this sounds feasible you might be
able to do it and you can actually it's
just very very expensive yeah yeah
exactly exactly so in a sense we do have
alchemy and
maybe even back then it wasn't as crazy
that he was so into it
but good people just don't like to talk
about that as much
yeah but newton in general is a very
interesting fellow
anybody else come to mind
in terms of
people that inspire you
in terms of people that you just
are happy that they have once or still
exist on this earth
i think i mean freeman dyson for me
yeah freeman dyson was was
i've had a chance to actually exchange a
couple of emails with him it was
probably one of the most humble
scientists that i've ever met and that
had a a big impact on me we were trying
we're actually trying to convince him to
annotate a paper on fermat's library
and i sent him an email asking him
if you could annotate a paper and his
response was something like i have very
limited knowledge i just know a couple
of things about certain fields i'm not
sure if i'm qualified to do that that
was his first response and
and this was someone that should have
won an opera fry's and worked on a bunch
of different fields um did some really
really
great work
and then just the interactions that i
had with him every time i asked him a
couple of questions about his papers and
uh he always responded saying i'm not
here to answer your questions i just
want to open it more questions
um and uh so that had a big impact on me
it was like just
an example of an extremely humble
yet
accomplished
uh scientist and feynman was also a big
big inspiration in the sense that he was
able to be
you know again extremely talented and
and scientists but at the same time
socially he was able to to he was also
really smart from a social perspective
and he was able to
interact with people it was also a
really good
teacher and was also to did a awesome
work in terms of um
explaining physics to to the masses and
motivating and getting people interested
in physics
and that for me was was also a big
inspiration
yeah i like the childlike curiosity of
some of those folks like you mentioned
freeman i have daniel kahneman i got a
chance to meet and interact with
some some of these truly special
scientists
what makes them special is that even in
uh older age
they're still
like there's still that fire of
childlike curiosity that burns
and uh some of that is like not taking
yourself so seriously that you think
you've figured it all out
but almost like thinking that you don't
know much of it
and
that's like step one in having a great
conversation or collaboration or
exploring a scientific question it's
cool how the very thing that probably
earned people the nobel prize or
or work that's seminal in some way
is the very thing that still burns even
after
uh they've won the prize it's cool to
see and they're rare humans
it seems and to that point i remember
like the last email that i sent to
freeman dyson was like in his last
birthday he was really into number
theory and primes so what i did is i
took like a photo of him a picture and
then i turned that into like
a giant prime number
so i converted the picture into a bunch
of one and eight and then i moved some
numbers around until it was a prime
um and then i sent him that
also the the visual like it still looked
like the picture it's made up of a
problem that's tricky to do it's hard to
do it looks harder than it actually is
so the the way you do it is like you
convert the darker regions into eights
and the lighter regions in ones
and then there's just keep flipping yeah
but there's like some primality tests
that are cheaper from a computational
standpoint yes but what it tells you is
it excludes numbers that are not prime
then you end up with a set of numbers
that you don't know if they are prime or
not and then you run the full primality
test on that so you just have to keep
iterating on that and it was it was it's
it's funny because when he got the
picture he was like how did you do that
it was super curious too and then we got
into the details and again this was he
was already 90 i think 92 or something
and that curiosity was still there um
so you could really see that in in some
of these scientists
so could we talk about vermont's library
yeah absolutely what
is it
what's the main goal what's the dream
it is a platform for annotating papers
in its essence right and so academic
papers can be one of the densest forms
of content out there and generally
pretty hard to understand at times and
the idea is that you can make them more
accessible and easier to understand by
adding these rich annotations to the
site right and so we can just imagine a
pdf view on your browser and then you
have annotations on each side and then
when you click on them a sidebar expands
and then you have
annotations that support latex and
markdown
and so the idea is that you can
say explain a tougher part of a paper
where there's a step that is not
completely obvious
or you can add more context to it
and then over time papers can become
easier and
easier to understand and can evolve in a
way but it really came from
myself luige and two other friends we've
been
we've had this this long-running habit
of kind of running a journal club
amongst us we come from different
backgrounds right i studied cs we
studied physics and so we read papers
and present them to each other and uh
and then we tried to bring some of that
online and that's that's that's when we
decided to to to build fermat's library
um
then over time it kind of
grew into into something uh with with a
broader goal uh
and really what we're trying to do is
trying to help
uh move science in the in the the right
direction
that's really the ultimate goal and and
where we want to take it now so there's
a lot to be said so first of all for
people who haven't seen it
the interface is exceptionally well done
that's like execution is really
important here absolutely the other
things just to mention
for
a large number of people apparently
which is new to me don't know what latex
is
so it's spelled like latex so be careful
googling it if you haven't before
uh it's uh
uh
sorry i don't even know the correct
terminology type setting it's a
typesetting language
where it's you're basically program
writing a program that then generates
something that looks
from a typography perspective beautiful
absolutely and uh so a lot of academics
use it to write papers i i think there's
like a bunch of communities that use it
to write papers i would say it's
mathematics physics computer science
yeah that's yeah that's the because i'm
collaborating currently on a paper with
uh two neuroscientists from stanford and
they don't know what
so i'm using uh microsoft word and uh
mendeley
and like all of those kinds of things
and it's
and i'm being very zen like about about
the whole process but it's fascinating
it's a little heartbreaking actually
because uh
it actually it's it's funny to say but
uh and we'll talk about open science
actually the bigger mission behind for
mars libraries like
really opening up the world of science
to everybody
is these silly
two facts of like one community uses
latex and another uses word
is actually a barrier between them
that's like it's like boring and
practical in a sense but it makes it
very difficult to collaborate
just on that like i think there if there
are some people that should have
received like a nobel prize that but
we'll never get it and i think one of
those is like donald knuth because of
tech and latex and then
because it had a huge impact in terms of
like just
making it easier for uh researchers to
put their content out there like making
it uniform as much as possible oh you
mean like a nobel peace prize well maybe
maybe a couple of peace prizes
maybe a nobel peace prize yeah
i
i think so i mean he at a very young age
got the touring award for his work in
algorithms and so on so yeah like an
incredible yeah like when i i think it's
in
it might be even the 60s but i think
it's the 70s that so when he was really
young and then he went on to do like
incredible work
with his book and uh yeah with tech that
people don't know and and going back
just one
on the reason why we we ended up because
i think this is interesting the reason
why we ended up using the name for mars
library this was because of uh vermont's
last theorem and from us livestream is
actually a funny story like so pierre de
fermat he was like a lawyer and he
wrote like on a book
that he had a solution to fermat's last
theorem which um but that didn't fit the
margin of that book
and so fermat's lie stream basically
states that there's no solution if you
have uh
integers a b and c there's no solution
to a to the power of n plus b to the
power of n equals to c to the power of
n
if n is bigger than two so there's
there's there's no solutions and
he said that
and
that problem remained open for almost
300 years i believe and a lot of the
most famous mathematicians tried to
tackle that problem no one was able to
figure that that out until andrea wiles
uh i think was in in the 90s was able to
publish the solution which was i i
believe almost 300 pages long
and so it's kind of an anecdote that you
know there's a lot of of knowledge and
insights that can be trapped
in the margins then you and there's a
lot of potential energy that you can
release if you actually um spend some
time trying to digest
that and that was the the the origin
story for
for the name yes you can share the
contents of the margins with the world
exactly that could inspire a solution or
a communication that then leads to a
solution but and and if you think about
papers like papers are as as jean was
saying probably one of the densest
pieces of text that
any human can read and you have these
researchers like some of the brightest
minds in in these fields working on like
new discoveries and publishing these
work on journals that are imposing them
restrictions in terms of the number of
pages that they can have to explain a
new scientific breakthrough so at the
end of the day papers are not optimized
for clarity and for a proper explanation
of of that content because there are so
many restrictions so there's as i
mentioned there's a lot of potential
energy that can be freed if you actually
try to digest a lot of the contents of
papers
can you explain some of the other things
so margins librarian journal club
so journal club is what a lot of people
know us for uh where we every week we
release an annotated paper and in all
sorts of different fields with physics
cs math
margins is kind of the same software
that we use to to run the journal club
and to host the annotations but we've
made that available for free to anybody
that wants to use it and so
folks use it at universities and
and
for running journal clubs
and and so we just made that freely
available and then librarian is a
browser extension that we developed that
is sort of an overlay on top of archive
so it's about bringing some of the same
functionality around comments plus
adding some extra
niceties to to archive like being able
to very easily extract the references of
a paper that you're looking at or being
able to extract the bibtex in order to
cite that paper yourself
so it's an overlay on top of archive the
idea is that you can have that
commenting interface without having to
leave archive it's kind of incredible i
didn't know about it
and once i've learned of it
it's like holy [ __ ]
why isn't it more popular given how
popular archive is like everybody should
be using it archive sucks
or uh let me rephrase that it's limited
yeah in terms of what's interesting
archive is a pretty incredible project
right and it is in in a way it's
it you know it the growth has been
completely linear over time if you look
at like number of papers published on
archive like you know it's just been
it's pretty much a straight line for the
past 20 years especially for you know
like if you're coming from a startup
background and then you were trying to
do archive you'd probably try like all
sorts of growth acts and like try to
to then maybe like have paid features
and things like that and that would kind
of maybe ruin it and so there's
there's a subtle balance there yeah and
i don't know what what aspects you can
change about it and yeah for some tools
in science it just takes time for them
to to grow archive is just turned 30 i
believe yeah and for for people that
don't know archive is these kind of
online repository where people put
preprints which are versions of the
papers before they actually make it to
journals
a-r-x-i-v exactly for people who don't
know and it's actually a really vibrant
place to publish your papers in in the
aforementioned
uh communities of mathematics exactly in
computer science it started with
mathematics and physics and then over
the the last 30 years it evolved and now
actually computer computer science now
it's it's a more popular category than
than physics and math on archive and
there's also which i don't know very
much about like a
biology medical version of that bio
archive yeah by archive um it's recent
it's um it's interesting because if you
look at like these um platforms for
preprints they are
they actually play a super important
role because
if you look at a category like math
for some papers in math it might take
close to three years
after you click upload paper on the
journal website and the paper gets
published on the website of the journal
so this is literally the longest
upload period on the internet
um and during those three years like
it's it's you know
their content is just you know locked
and so this that's why it's so important
for people to have websites like archive
so that you can share that before it
goes to the journal with the rest of the
world there was actually on archive that
uh perumann published the the three
pipers that led to the proof of the
poincare conject conjecture and then you
have other fields like
machine learning for instance where the
the field is evolving at such a high
rate that people don't even wait before
the papers go to journals before they
start working on top of those papers so
they publish them on archive then other
people see them they start working on
that and archive did a really good job
at like building that core platform to
host papers but i i think there's a
really really big opportunity in
building more features on top of that
platform apart from just hosting paper
so collaboration annotations and
like having other things apart from from
papers like code um
and and other things because uh in the
field like machine learning there's a
really big you know as i mentioned
people start working on on top of
preprints and they are assuming that
that
that preprint is correct
but you really need a way for instance
to maybe
it's not peer review but
distinguish what is good work from bad
work on archive how do you do that so
like a commenting interface like
librarian it's useful for that so that
you can distinguish that um at
in the field that is growing so fast as
machine learning and um and then you
have
platforms that focus for instance on
just biology bioarchive is a good
example um
bioarchive is also super interesting
because there there's actually
an interesting experiment that was run
in the 60s so in the 60s the nih um
supported this pro this
this experiment called the information
exchange group
which at the time was a way for
researchers to share biology preprints
via mail or using libraries and that
project in the 1960s got cancelled six
years after it started and it was due to
intense pressure from the journals to
kill that project because they they were
fearing a competition from from the
uh
for in for the journal industry creek uh
was also uh was one of the famous
scientists that opposed
to to the uh information exchange group
and it's interesting because right now
if you analyze the number of biology
papers that
appear first as preprints it's only two
percent of the papers
and it this was almost 50 almost 50
years after that first experiment so you
can see like that pressure from the
journals to cancel that uh initial
version of a pre-print repo had a
tremendous impact on on on the number of
papers that are showing up in biology as
preprints so it delayed a lot that
that revolution and um
but now platforms like bioarchive are
doing that work but there's still a lot
of room for growth there and i think
it's super important because those are
the papers that are open that everyone
can read
okay so but if we just look at the
entire process of science as a big
system can we just talk about how it can
be revolutionized
so
you have an idea
uh depending on the field you want to
make that idea concrete you want to run
a few experiments in computer science
there might be some code
there'd be a data set
for you know some of the more sort of
biology
psychology
you might be collecting the data set
that's called you know a study right
so that's part of that that's part of
the methodology and so you are putting
all that into a paper form
and then
you have some results
and then you you submit that to a place
for
review through the peer review process
and there's a process where how would
you summarize the peer review process
but it's it's really just like a handful
of people look over your paper and
comment and based on that decide whether
your paper is good or not
so there's a whole broken nature to it
at the same time i love the peer review
process when i buy stuff on amazon
like uh
for like uh the commenting system
whatever that is so okay so there's a
bunch of possibilities for revolutions
there and then there's the other side
which is the collaborative aspect of the
science which is people annotating
people commenting sort of the low effort
collaboration which is a comment
sometimes as you've talked about a
comment can change everything but you
know or a higher effort collaboration
like more like maybe annotations or even
like contributing to the paper you can
think of like
a
collaborative updating of the paper over
time
so there's all these possibilities for
doing things
better than they've been done
can we talk about some ideas in this
space some ideas that you're working on
some ideas that uh you're not yet
working on but should be revolutionized
because it does seem
that archive and like open review for
example
are like the craigslist of science like
like
yeah okay i'm very grateful that we have
it but it just feels like
it's like 10 to 20 years like it doesn't
feel like that's a feature the
simplicity of it is a feature it feels
like it's a it's a bug
[Music]
but then again the the pushback there is
uh wikipedia has the same kind of
simplicity to it
and it seems to work exceptionally well
in the crowdsourcing aspect of it i'm
sorry this there's a bunch of stuff
going on on the table let's just pick
random things that we can talk about
wikipedia you know for me it's the
cosmological constant of the internet
it's like i think we are lucky to live
in the parallel universe where wikipedia
exists yes because if if someone had
pitched me wikipedia like a publicly
edited
encyclopedia like a couple of years ago
like it would be i don't know how many
people would have said that that would
have
survived
yeah i mean it makes almost no sense
it's like having a google doc that
everybody on the internet can edit and
like that will be like the most reliable
source for for knowledge and i don't
know how many but hundreds of thousands
of topics yeah exactly
it's insane it's insane and like you
have and then you have users like
there's one a single user that edited
one third of the articles on wikipedia
so you have these really really big
power users there are a substantial part
of like what makes wikipedia
successful and so
like
no one would have ever imagined that
that could happen
um and so that that's that's one thing i
i completely agree with what you just
said i also started to interrupt briefly
maybe let's inject that into the
discussion of everything else
i also believe i've seen that with stack
overflow that one individual or a small
collection of individuals contribute or
revolutionize
most of the community like if you create
a really powerful system for archive
or like open review it made it really
easy
and compelling
and exciting for one person who isn't
like a 10x contributor to do their thing
that's going to change everything it
seems like that was the mechanism that
changed everything for wikipedia and
that's the mechanism that changed
everything for stack overflow is
gamifying or making it exciting or just
making it fun or pleasant or fulfilling
in some way for those people who are
insane
enough to like answer thousands of
questions or
write thousands of factoids and like
research them and check them all those
kinds of things or read thousands of
papers yeah no stack overflow is another
great example of that and it's just
and and those are both to
incredibly productive communities that
generate a ton of value and and and
capture almost none of it right and it's
and you know in a way it's almost like
counter um
it's very counter-intuitive that that
that people that these communities would
exist and thrive um
and and it's really hard to
you there aren't that many communities
like that so how do we do that for
science do you have ideas there like
what are the biggest problems that you
see you're working on some of them
like just on that there are a couple of
really interesting experiments that
people are running an example would be
like the polymath projects so this is a
so kind of a social experiment that was
uh created by tim gowers
fields fields medalist and his idea was
to try to prove that is it possible to
do mathematics in a massively
collaborative collaborative way on the
internet so we decided to pick a couple
of problems and
test that and they found out that it it
actually it is possible for a specific
types of problems
namely problems that you're able to
break down in in little pieces and go
step by step you might need as as with
open source you might need people that
are just kind of reorganizing the the
house every once in a while and then you
know people throw a bunch of ideas and
then you know you make some progress
then you reorganize you reframe the
problem you go step by step but they
were actually able to prove that it is
possible to to
uh collaborate online and and
do progress in terms of mathematics um
and so i'm i'm confident that there are
other avenues that could be explored
here can we talk about peer review for
example absolutely i i think like in in
terms of the peer review i think we it's
it's important to look at the bigger
picture here of like
of what this scientific the scientific
publishing ecosystem looks like because
for me
there there are a lot of things that are
wrong about that entire process so
if you look at for instance at the what
publishing means in like a traditional
journal you have uh journals that pay um
authors
for their articles and then they might
pay like reviewers to um review those
articles and finally they pay
people to um or distributors to
distribute the content
in in the scientific publishing world
you have scientists that are usually
backed by government grants they are
giving away their work for free in the
form of papers
and then you have other scientists that
are reviewing their work
this process is known as the peer review
process again for free
and then finally we have um
government-backed universities and
libraries that are buying back
all those
all that work so that other scientists
can we can read so this is for me it's
bizarre you have the government that is
funding the research is paying the
salaries of the scientists it's paying
the salaries of the reviewers and it's
buying back all that uh the product of
their work again
um and i think the problem with this
system and it's what it's why it's so
difficult to to break this
suboptimal equilibrium is because of of
the way academia works right now and the
way you can progress in in your academic
life
and and so
in a lot of fields the the competition
in academia is is really insane
so you have hundreds of phd students
there are um trying to get to
a professor position and and it's hyper
competitive and the only way for you to
get there
is if you publish papers ideally in
journals with a
high impact factor in computer science
it's all it's often conferences are also
very prestigious or actually more
prestigious than journals now
so interesting so that's the one
discipline where i mean that has to do
with the thing we've discussed uh in
terms of the how quickly the field turns
around but like uh in eurips cvpr those
conferences are more prestigious or at
the very least as prestigious as the
journal
but doesn't matter the process is what
it is and and and so with the the so for
people that don't know how the impact
factor of a journal is basically the
average number of citations that a paper
would get if it gets published on that
journal
but so um you can really think that
the problem with the the impact factor
is that it's a way to turn papers into
accounting units
and and and let me unpack this because
it's the impact factor is almost like a
nobility title so because papers are
born with impact even before anyone
reads them so the researchers they don't
have the incentive
to care about if this paper is going to
ever a long-term impact on on on the
world what they care their goal their
end goal is the paper to get published
yes so that they get that value up front
and so for me that that is one of the
problems of of that and that really
creates a tyranny of of metrics
because at the end of the day if you are
a dean what you want to hire is like
people researchers that publish papers
on journals with high impact factors
because that will increase the ranking
of your university and will allow you to
charge more for tuition so on and so
forth and um and and that that
especially when you are in super
competitive areas you know that people
will try to gamify that system and and
misconduct starts showing up
um there's a a really interesting book
on this topic called gaming the metrics
it's a book by a researcher called mario
biagioli it goes a lot into like how
these
the impact factor and metrics affect
science negatively and it's interesting
to think especially in terms of
citations if you look at the early work
of like looking at citations there was a
lot of work that was done by a guy
called eugene garfield and this guy
the early work in terms of citation they
wanted to use they wanted to use
citations as
from a descriptive point of view so what
they wanted to to create was a map
and and that map would create a visual
representation of of influence so
citations would be links
between papers and the ideally what they
would show they would represent is that
you read someone else's paper and it had
an impact on your research they weren't
supposed to be counted i think this
inspired like larry and sergey's exactly
worked right for google exactly i think
they even mentioned that but what
happens is like as you start counting
citations you create a market
and and the same way like and this was
the the work of eugene garfield was a
big inspiration for larry and sergey for
the pagerank algorithm that um you know
led to the creation of google and they
even recognize that and and if you think
about it's like the same way there's a
gigantic market for search engine
optimization uh seo where people try to
optimize you know the the page rank and
how i the uh of a web page will rank on
google the same will happen for papers
people will try to optimize like their
site their the impact factors and the
citations that they get and that um
creates a really big problem and if it's
super interesting to actually analyze
them if you look at the distribution of
the high impact the impact factors of
journals you have like nature with
nature i believe it's like in the low
40s and then you have i believe science
is high 30s and then you have a really
goo
a good set of good journals that
will
fall between 10 and 30 and then you have
a gigantic tale of of journals that have
impact factor below two and you can
really see two economies here you see
the the
you know the universities that are maybe
less prestigious less known that where
the faculty are pressured to just
publish papers regardless of the journal
what i want to do is increase the
ranking of my university and so they end
up publishing as many papers as as they
they can in like journals with low
impact factor and unfortunately this is
represents a lot of of the global south
and then you have the luxury good
economy
so for instance for and there are also
problems here in the luxury good economy
so if you look at the journal like
nature
so with impact factor of like in the low
40s
there's no way that you're going to be
able to sustain that level of impact
factor by just grabbing the attention of
scientists
what what i mean by that is like
for for the journals the articles that
get published in nature they need to be
new york times great so they need to
make it to the you know to the to the
big media they need to be captured by
the big media and because that's the
only way for you to capture enough
attention to sustain that level of
citations yes and that of course creates
problems because people then will try to
again gamify the system and have like
titles or abstracts or that are
bigger claim make claims that are bigger
than what is actually can be um
you know sustained by by the data or the
the content of the paper and you'll have
clickbait titles or clickbait abstracts
and again this is all a consequence of
metrics and uh scientometrics and and
this is a very dangerous cycle that i
think it's very hard to break
but it's happening in academia in a lot
of fields right now
is it fundamentally the existence of
metrics or the metrics just need to be
significantly improved
because uh
like i said the metrics used for amazon
for purchasing
i don't know
computer parts it's pretty damn good in
terms of selecting which are the good
ones which are not
in that same way if if we had an amazon
type of review system in the space of
ideas in the space of science it feels
like that those metrics would be a
little bit better
sort of when it's um
when it's significantly
more open to the crowd source nature of
the internet
of the of the scientific internet
meaning as opposed to like my biggest
problem with peer review
has always been
that it's like
five six seven people
usually even less and it's often
nobody's incentivized to do a good job
in the whole process
meaning
it's anonymous
in a way that
doesn't incentivize like doesn't gamify
or incentivize
great work
and also
it doesn't necessarily have to be
anonymous like there has to be um
the entire system is um
doesn't encourage actual sort of
rigorous review for example like
open review
does kind of incentivize that kind of
process of collaborative review but it's
also imperfect it just feels like
the thing that amazon has which is like
thousands of people contributing their
reviews to a product
it feels like that could be applied to
science
where
the same kind of thing you're doing with
vermont's library
but doing at a scale that's much larger
it feels like that should be possible
given the number of grad students
given the number of um
general public that get like for example
i
personally as a person
who got an education in mathematics and
computer science like
uh i can i can be a quote-unquote like
reviewer
on a lot bigger set of things than than
is my exact uh expertise
if i'm one of thousands of reviewers if
i'm the only reviewer or one of five
then i'd better be like an expert in the
thing but if if i uh and i've learned
this with covet which is like
you can just use your basic skills as a
data analyst as a and to contribute to
the review process and a particular
little aspect of a paper and be able to
comment be able to sort of uh
draw in some references that challenge
the ideas presented or to enrich the
ideas that are presented or you know and
it just feels like crowdsourcing
the review process would be able to
allow you to have
metrics
in terms of how good a paper is that are
much better representative of its actual
impact in the world of its actual value
to the world as opposed to some kind of
arbitrary gamified
version of its impact
i agree with that i i think we there's
definitely the possibility at least for
more resilient a more resilient system
than what we have today and that's i
think that's kind of what you're
describing alex and and i mean to an
extent we we kind of have like a little
bit of a
heisenberg uncertainty principle when
you pick a metric as soon as you do it
then maybe it works as a good heuristic
for for a short amount of time but soon
enough people would start gamifying and
yeah
but but then you can definitely have
metrics that are more resilient to
gamification and they'll work as a
better heuristic to to try to push you
in the in
the best direction
but i guess the underlying problem
you're saying is uh there's a shortage
of positions in academia that's a big
problem for me yeah and and that and so
they're going to be constantly gamifying
the metrics it's a bit of a zero-sum
it's very competitive it's what it's a
very competitive field and and that's
what usually happens in very competitive
fields yeah yeah
but i think some of like the peer review
problems like scale helps i think and
and it's interesting to look at like
what you're mentioning breaking it down
maybe in my smaller parts and having
more people jumping in
um but
th this is definitely a problem and and
the peer review problem as i mentioned
is
is correlated with the problem of like
academic career progression and it's all
intertwined and it's what that's why i
think it's so hard to to break it
um there are like a couple of really
interesting things that are being done
right now there are a couple of for
instance journals that are overlaid
journals on top of
platforms like archive and bioarchive
that want to remove like the more
traditional journals from the equation
so essentially a journal is just a
collection of links to papers and and um
and what they are trying to do is like
removing that middleman and trying to to
make the review process a little bit
more transparent
um
and and and not charging universities
like uh there's there's a couple of
there are a couple of more famous um
ones there's one discrete analysis in
mathematics there's one uh called the
quantum journal which we are actually
working with them we have a partnership
with them for the purpose that get
published in quantum journal they also
get the annotations on formats um and
they are doing pretty well they've been
able to grow substantially the problem
there is getting to critical mass so
it's again convincing the researchers
and especially the young researchers
that need
need that impact factor need those
publications to have citations to not
publish on the traditional journal and
go on an open journal and and publish
their work there there i think there are
a couple of really high-profile
scientists of people like team gowers
that are trying to
incentivize like
famous scientists that already have
tenure and that don't need that to
publish that to increase the reputation
of those journals so that other maybe
younger scientists can start publishing
on on those as well and so they can try
to break that vicious cycle of
of um the more traditional journals i
mean another possible way to break this
cycle is to
like raise public awareness and just by
force like ban paid journals
like what exactly are they contributing
to the world
like basically making it illegal
to uh
forget the fact that it's mostly
federally funded so that's that's a
super ugly picture too
but like why should knowledge be
so expensive
like where everyone is working for the
public good
and then there's these gatekeepers
that you know most people can't read
most papers
without having to pay money and
that's that doesn't make any sense
that's like that that should be illegal
i mean that's what you're saying is
exactly right i mean for instance right
i i went to school here in the us we
studied in europe and
you would sit like you'd ask me all the
time to download papers and send it to
him because he just couldn't get it and
like papers that he needed for his
research and so but he's a student like
he's yeah he's a grad student he was a
grad student but that you know
i'm even referring to just regular
people oh yeah okay that too yeah and i
i think uh during 2020
because of covet a lot of journals put
down the
walls for certain kind of coronavirus or
papers
but like that just gave me an indication
that like
this should be done for everything it's
it's absurd like people should be
outraged that there's these gates
because
so the moment you dissolve the journals
then there will be an opportunity for
startups
to uh build stuff on top of archive it'd
be an opportunity for like
vermont's library to step up to scale up
to something much even larger i mean
that was the original dream of uh
google which i
always admired which is make the world's
information accessible actually it's
interesting that google hasn't maybe you
guys can correct me but they uh put
together google scholar which is
incredible
but they and they've did the scanning of
books but they've haven't really
tried to make science accessible
in the in the in the following way like
besides doing google scholar they
haven't like
delved into the papers
right mm-hmm which is especially curious
given what louise was saying right that
it's kind of in their genesis there's
this
you know research that was very
connected with our papers reference each
other and like building a network out of
that
interesting enough like google but i
think there was a there was not intent
google plus was like the google social
network that got canceled was used by a
lot of researchers yes it was uh whether
i think was just a you know side kind of
a side effect but then a lot of people
ended up migrating to twitter but it was
not on purpose but yeah i agree with you
like they haven't
um gone past the google scholar and well
you know what that said google's call is
incredible people who are not familiar
it's one of the best
aggregation of all the scientific work
that's out there and especially the
network that connects to all of them
what sites what and also trying to
aggregate all the versions of the papers
that are available there and trying to
merge them in a way that uh one
particular work even though it's
available in a bunch of places counts as
you know like a central hub of what that
work is across the multiple versions but
that almost seems like a fun
project of a couple of engineers within
within google as opposed to a serious
effort to make the world's science
accessible but but going back to just
the
the journals when you're talking about
that lex i i believe that
in that front i think we might be past
the event horizon so i think the
the the model the business model for the
journals you know doesn't make sense
they are a middle layer that is not
adding a lot of value and you see a lot
of motions whereas like in europe a lot
of the the
papers that are get
are funded by the european union they
will have to be um uh
open to the public and i think there's a
lot of bill gates to like the the what
the gates foundation funds like they
they demand that it then it that it's uh
accessible to everybody oh interesting
so i think it's it's the question of
time before that that wall kind of falls
and and that is going to open a lot of
possibilities um because you know
imagine if if you had like the layer of
like that gigantic layer of papers all
available online
um you know that unlocks a lot of
potential as a platform for people to
build things on top of that but i think
it's what you're saying it is weird like
you can literally
go and listen to any song that was ever
made
on your phone right you open spotify and
you might not even pay for it you might
be on the free version and you can
listen to any song that has ever made
pretty much
but
there's like you you don't have access
to a huge percentage of academic papers
which is just like this fundamental
knowledge that we're all funding but you
as an individual don't have access to it
and and somehow you know like the
problem for music got solved
uh but for papers it's still like it's
just not yet it could be ad supported
all those kinds of things and that
hopefully that would change the way we
do science that's the most exciting
thing for me
is uh especially once i started like
making videos in this
silly podcast thing i started to realize
like
that if you want to do science one of
the most effective ways is to do uh like
couple
the paper with a set of youtube videos
like explaining it like
yeah that also seems like there's a lot
of room for disruption there what is the
paper 2.0 gonna look like i think like
latex and the pdf
seems like if you
it's interesting if you look at the
first paper that got published in nature
and if you look at the paper that got
published in nature today look at the
two side by side they are fundamentally
the same
and
even though like the paper that gets
published today you know
you get even even code like right now
people put like code like on on a pdf
like and
there are so many things that are
related to papers today you know you use
you have data you have code um you might
need videos to to better explain the
concepts so it's it i i think for me
it's natural that there's going to be
also an evolution there that papers are
not going to be just the static pdfs or
latex
there's going to be a next uh next
interface so in academia a lot of things
that are judged your judge by is often
quantity not quality
i i wonder if there's a opportunity to
have like
i tend to judge people by the best work
they've ever done as opposed to
i wonder if there's a possibility for
that to encourage sort of um focusing on
the quality
and not necessarily in paper form but
maybe a subset of a paper subset of idea
almost even a blog post or an experiment
like why does it have to be published in
a journal
yeah to be
legitimate
and and it's just interesting that he
mentioned that i also think like yeah
it's why why why is that the only format
why can't a blog post or
uh we were even experimenting
experimenting with these a few months
ago or can you actually like publish
something
or
um
like a new scientific breakthrough or um
or something that you've discovered in
the form of like a set of tweets
yeah the twitter thread why can't that
be possible
and um
we were expanding experimenting with
that idea uh we even um yeah we ran a
couple of of like some people submitted
a couple of those like i think the limit
was three or four tweets yeah uh maybe
it's a new way to look at a you know a
proof or something but uh i think it
just serves to show that there should be
other ways to publish like scientific
discoveries that don't fit the paper
format well
but so even with the twitter
thread
it would be
it would be nice to have some mechanism
of formalizing it and making it stat
making it into an nft
like
a concrete thing that you can reference
is a link that's unique
because uh i mean everything we've been
saying
all of that
while being true
it's also true that
the
constraints and the formalism of a paper
works well it like forces you
constraints forces you to narrow down
your thing and
and uh literally put it on paper
but you know
i agree uh make concrete and that's why
i mean it's not broken it's just could
be better and that's the main idea i
think there's something about writing
whether it's a blog post or twitter
thread or a paper
that's really nice to to concretize a
particular little
idea that they can then be referenced by
other ideas then it can be built on top
of with other ideas
so uh let me ask you've read quite a few
papers
you've uh annotated quite a few papers
let's talk about the process itself how
do you advise people read papers
or maybe you want to broaden it beyond
just papers but just
read
concrete pieces of information to
understand the insights that lay within
i would say for paper specifically i
would i would bring back kind of what
louise was talking about it is that it's
important to keep in mind that papers
are not optimized for ease of
understanding and so right there's all
sorts of restrictions in size
and format and and language that they
can use and so it's important to keep
that in mind and so that if you're
struggling to read a paper doesn't
that might not mean that the underlying
material is actually that hard
and so
so that's definitely something that that
especially for us that we we read papers
and most of the times the lead papers
are completely outside of our
of our comfort zone i guess and and to
be completely new areas to us um
so i always try to to keep that in mind
so there's usually a certain kind of
structure like abstract introductions
methodology
uh depending on the community and so on
is there something about
the process of like how to read it
whether you want to skim it to try to
find the parts that are easy to
understand or not
uh reading it multiple times
is there any kind of hacks that you can
comment on i remember like feynman had
this this kind of hack when it was
reading papers where
he would basically
um
would i think i believe he would read
the conclusion of the paper
and we would try to just um see if he
would be able to figure out how to get
to the conclusion in like a couple of
minutes by himself
and um and he would read a lot of papers
that way and i think fermi also did that
almost and fermi was known for doing a
lot of back of the envelope calculation
so he was a master at doing that um
in terms of like especially when
when reading a paper i think a lot of
times people might
feel discouraged about the first time
you read it
you know it's very hard to grasp or you
don't understand a huge fraction of the
paper
and i think it's having read a lot of
papers in my life i think i've in peace
with like the fact that you might spend
hours where you're just reading a paper
and jumping from paper to paper reading
citations
and um like your level of understanding
of sometimes of the paper is very close
to zero percent and all of a sudden you
know everything kind of
makes sense and and in your mind and
then you know you have this quantum jump
where all of a sudden you you you
understanding the big picture of the
paper and uh i i
and and this is an exercise that i have
to when reading papers and especially
like more complex papers like okay you
don't understand because you're just
going through the process and just keep
going and like and it
might feel super chaotic especially if
you are jumping from reference to
reference you know you might end up with
like 20 tabs open and you're reading a
ton of other papers but it's just
trusting that process
that at the end like you'll find light
and i think for me that's a good
framework
when reading a paper it's hard
because you know you might end up
spending a lot of time and you it looks
like you're lost
but uh but
that's the process to actually um you
know understand what they're talking
about in the paper
yeah i think that process
i enjoy i've found a lot of value in the
process especially for things outside my
field
of reading a lot of related work
sections and kind of go going down that
path of getting a big context of the
field because
what's especially when they're well
written
there's opinions injected into the
related work like what work is important
what is not and if you read multiple
related work sections that cite or don't
cite each other like the papers
you get a sense of where the field where
the tensions of the field are
where this where the field is striving
and that helps you put into context like
whether the work is radical whether it's
overselling it itself whether it's
underselling itself all those things
uh and on adding on top of that
i find that often the related work
section
is the most
kind of accessible and readable part of
a paper because it's kind of uh it's
brief to the point it's trying like
summarizing it's almost like a wikipedia
style article
the introduction is supposed to be a
compelling story or whatever but it's
often like overselling there's like an
agenda in the introduction
the related work usually has the least
amount of agenda except for the few
like elements where you're trying to uh
talk [ __ ] about previous work where
you're trying to sell that you're doing
much better but other than that when
you're just painting where the where the
field
came from or where the field stands
that's really valuable and also again
just to agree with finding the
conclusion it's like i get a lot of
value from the
breadth first search kind of read the
conclusion
then read the related work and then
go through the references in the related
work read the conclusion read the
related work and just go down the tree
until you like hit dead ends or run out
of coffee and then through that process
you go back up the tree and now you can
see the results in their proper
in their proper context unless of course
the paper is truly revolutionary which
even that process will help you
understand that is in fact truly
revolutionary
you've also um
you talked about just following your
twitter thread in a
depth first search you talked about that
you read uh
the book on
grisha pearlman go to brahman
and then you would you had a really nice
twitter thread on it and
you were taking notes throughout so
at a high level is there suggestions you
can give on how to take good notes
whether it's we're talking about
annotations or just for yourself to try
to
put on paper ideas as you progress
through the work in order to then like
understand the work better for me i
always try not to underestimate how much
you can forget uh within six months
right after you've read something i
thought you're gonna say five minutes
but yeah six months is good yeah or
or even shorter and so
that's something i always try to keep in
mind and uh and it's and it's often i
mean
every once in a while i'll read back a
paper that i annotated on vermont and
it's and uh and i'll read through my own
annotations and it's uh and i've
completely forgotten what i had written
and but it also
it also it's interesting because in a
way after you just understood something
you're kind of the best possible teacher
that can teach your future self
uh yeah you know after you've forgotten
it uh
you can you're kind of your own best
possible teacher at that moment and so
it's it can be great to try to capture
that
it's it's brilliant it just made me kind
of
realize
it's really nice to to put yourself in
the position of teaching an older
version of yourself exactly that returns
to this paper almost like thinking it
literally
that's underexplored
but it's it's super powerful because you
were the person that you can like if you
if you look at the scale from like one
not knowing anything about the topic and
ten
like you are the one that progressed
from one to ten and you know which steps
you struggled with so you're the really
the best person to help yourself make
that transition from one to ten
and um a lot of the times like
and we don't i really believe that the
framework there we have to like just
expose ourselves to like be talking to
like us when we were an expert when we
were taking that class and we knew
everything about quantum mechanics and
then six months later you don't remember
half of the things how could we make it
easier for a like to
have those conversations between you and
your past self past expert self
um
i i think there there might be you know
it's an underexplored idea i think notes
on paper are probably not the best way
i'm not sure if it's a combination of
like video
audio where it's like you have a guided
framework that you follow to extract
information from yourself so that you
can later kind of revisit
to make it easier to to remember but
that's i think it's an interesting idea
worth worth exploring that not i've i
haven't seen a lot of people kind of
trying to
uh distill that problem
you know i'm creating the kind of tools
i find if i record it it sounds weird
but i'll take notes but if i record
audio
like um like little clips of thoughts
like rants
that's really effective at capturing
something that notes can't
because when i replay them for some
reason
it loads my brain back into where i was
when i was reading that in a way that
notes don't like when i read notes i'll
often be like what what
what was i what was i thinking there but
when i listened to the audio yeah it
brings you right back to that place so
there might and
maybe with video with visual that might
be even more powerful i think so yeah
and and i think just the process of
you know verbalizing it
that alone kind of makes you have to
structure your thought and and put it in
a way that somebody else could come and
understand it and and just the process
of that is useful to to organize your
thoughts and and
and um yeah just just that alone does
the firmware's library journal club have
a like a video component or no
we no not natively we sometimes will
include uh videos but it's always
embedded do people like build videos on
top of it to explain the paper because
you're doing all the hard work of
understanding deeply the paper
not we haven't seen that happening too
much but uh we were we were actually
playing around with the idea of creating
some sort of podcast version where we
try to distill the paper
on an audio format that not maybe you
could have access
might be trickier but you there's
definitely people that could be
interested in the paper in that topic
but are not willing to read it but they
might listen to a 30 minute episode on
that paper yes you could reach more
people and and you might even bring the
authors to the conversation but it's
tricky especially for like more
technical papers we've we've thought
about that doing that but we haven't uh
like converge so if you have any
uh well i'm gonna take that as a a small
project to take one of you one of the
females almost like
half advertisement and half as a
challenge for myself to take take one of
the annotated papers and like use it as
a basis for creating a
quick video
i i i've seen like um
hopefully i'm saying the name correctly
but
machine learning street talk
i think that's the name of the show the
that i recommend highly that's the right
thing
but uh they they do exactly that which
is multiple hour breakdown of a paper
with video component
sometimes with authors
um people love it it's very effective
there's there's also i've seen i haven't
seen the entire in its entirety but i've
seen like the the founder of comma dot
ai george yeah i've seen him like just
taking a paper and then
you know distilling the paper and coding
it coding it sometimes during 10 hours
yeah and um he was able to you know get
a lot of people interested in in that
and viewing him so i'm a huge fan of
that
like uh
george is a personality i think a lot of
people like listen to this podcast for
the same reason it's not necessarily the
contents it's they they they like to
listen to like a
a silly
russian who has a childlike brain and
mumbles and all those like struggle with
ideas right and george is a madman who
people just enjoy like how is he going
to struggle in implementing this
particular paper how is he going to
struggle with this idea it's fun to
watch and that actually pulls you in the
personality is important there true but
there's lots there's you know i agree
with you but they're also it's visible
like it's
there's an extraordinary ability that is
there like is talented and you need to
have
there's a craft and this guy definitely
has talent and he's doing something that
is not easy and i think that also draws
the attention of people oh yeah and and
like the other day we were actually we
ran into this youtube channel of this
guy that was restoring art
right um yeah and
and um it was basically just a video of
him like his the production is really uh
like really well done and it's just him
taking really old um pieces of of art
like and then paintings and then
restoring them but he's really good at
that and he describes that process and
that draws attention uh draws the
attention of people regardless of your
craft be it like annotating your paper
or like responsibilities
excellence yeah like george is
incredibly good at programming
like quick like you know those uh
competitive programmers like top motor
and all this kind of stuff he has the
same kind of element where the brain
just jumps around really quickly and
that's uh yeah
just
like yeah it's motivating but but
and you're right in in watching people
who are good at what they do it's
motivating even if the thing you're
trying to do is not what they're doing
it's just like contagious when they're
really good at it and the same kind of
analysis with the paper i think
so not just like the final result but
the process yeah struggling with it
that's really interesting yeah i think i
mean i think twitch proved that like
you know that there's really a market
for for that for watching people
do things that they're really good at
and
and you'll just watch it you will enjoy
that that that might even uh spike your
interest in that specific topic and
yeah and people people will enjoy
watching sometimes hours on end of
yeah great craftsmen
do you mind if we talk about some of the
papers do any papers come to mind
that have been annotated on the
vermont's library
the papers that we annotated can be
about completely random topics but
that's part of what we enjoy as well it
forces you to explore these topics that
otherwise maybe you'd never run into
uh and so
so the ones that come to mind that to me
are fairly random but one that i i
really enjoyed
learning more about is um a paper
uh written by a mathematician actually
tom apostol and uh about a
a tunnel
in uh greek island off the coast of
turkey
i think it's already random
so this uh okay so what's interesting
about this tunnel so this tunnel um was
built in the sixth century bc
and um
and it was built in this
in the island of samos uh which is as i
said off the coast of turkey and um
right they had the city on one side and
the other mountain and then they had
a bunch of springs on the other side and
they they wanted to bring water into the
city
um did building an aqueduct would be
pretty hard because of the way the
mountain was shaped and it would also
you know if they if they were under a
siege like
they could just um easily destroy that
aqueduct and then the water wouldn't
have any water supply the the city
wouldn't have any water supply and so
they decided to build a tunnel
and they decided to try to do it quickly
um and so
the
they started digging
uh from both ends at the same time
through the mountain right and so
like when you start thinking about this
it's it's a fairly difficult problem and
this is like 6th century bc so
you had very limited access
to you know the mathematical tools that
you had at the time were very limited
and so what this paper is about is about
the story of how they built it and about
the fact that for about 2000 years kind
of the accepted the accepted explanation
of how they built it was actually wrong
and so this tunnel has been famous for a
while there are a number of historians
that talked about it since ancient egypt
and um and the method that they
described uh for for building it um is
is
uh was just wrong and and so these these
researchers went there and and were able
to figure figure that out and so
basically kind of the way that they
thought they had built it was basically
if you can imagine looking at the
mountain from the top and you have the
mountain and then you have both
entrances um
and so what they what they thought and
what this is what the ancient historians
described is that they
effectively tried to draw a right angle
a right angle triangle um
with the two entrances at each end of
the hypotenuse and the way they did is
like they would go around the mountain
and kind of walk in a grid fashion and
then you can you can figure out uh the
two sides
of the triangle and then after you have
that triangle you can
effectively draw two smaller triangles
at each entrance that are
proportional to that big triangle
and then you kind of have arrows
pointing in each way
and then you can you know at least that
these that you have a line going through
the the mountain that connects both
entrances
the issue with that is like once you
once you go to this mountain and you
start thinking of doing this you realize
that especially given that the tools
that they had at the time that your
error margin would be too small
you wouldn't be able to do it uh you you
you
the just the fact of of trying to to
build this triangle in that fashion the
error would accumulate and you would end
up missing you'd start building these
tunnels and they would miss each other
so the task ultimately is to figure out
like really perfectly as cl as close as
possible the direction you should be
digging first of all that it's possible
to have a straight line through and then
what that the direction would be and
then you're trying to infer that by
constructing a right triangle
by doing i i'm not exactly sure about
how to do that rigorously like by
tracing the mountain by walking along
the mountain how to you said grids yeah
you kind of walk as if you were in a in
a grid and so you just walk in right
angles i so right but then you have to
walk really precisely then exactly you
have to use tools to measure this and
then the terrain is probably yeah very
messed up so this makes more sense in 2d
and 3d gets even weirder
so okay gotcha but so this method was
described by like an ancient egyptian
historian i think hero of alexandria and
um and then for about like yeah for
about 2000 years that's that's how like
that's how we thought that they had
built this this tunnel um
and then in the end then these
researchers went there and and found out
that actually they they must have had to
to use other methods and and then in
this paper they describe these these
other methods and of course they can't
know for sure but there's uh they
presented a bunch of plausible
alternatives the one that for me was is
the most plausible is that what they
probably must have done is to use
something that is similar to
an iron sight on a rifle the way you can
line up uh your rifle with the target
off in the distance by by having an iron
sight
um
and uh and they they they must have done
something similar to that effectively
with tree with three sticks and that way
they were able to
line up
sticks
along the side of the mountain that were
all on the same height
and so that then you could get to the
other side and you could cut and then
you could draw that line
so this for me is the most plausible
way that they might have done that and
they
but then they they they describe this in
detail and other possible approaches in
this paper so this is a mathematician
doing this yeah this is a mathematician
that did this um which i suppose is the
right
mindset instead of skills required to
solve an ancient problem right yeah
yeah there's mathematicians and
engineers a lot of things because they
didn't have uh computers or drones or
lidar back then or whatever technology
you would use modern day for civil
engineering yeah and another fascinating
thing is that like
you know after
effectively after the the downfall of
the roman civilization people didn't
build tunnels for about a thousand years
we go a thousand years without tunnels
and then like only in like in late
middle ages that we start doing them
again but uh but here is the tunnel like
6th century bc like incredibly limited
mathematics and they and they build it
in this way um
and and and for and it was a mystery for
for a long time exactly how they did it
and then these mathematicians went there
and and uh
and and basically with no archaeology
kind of background we're able to figure
it out how do annotations for this paper
look like what is it uh what's a
successful annotation for paper like
this
yes so sometimes you're uh for this
paper um
sometimes adding some more context uh on
on a specific um
part like sometimes they they mentioned
for instance um
these
instruments that were common in ancient
greece and an ancient rome
for for building things and uh and and
so in some of those annotations i
described these instruments in more
detail and how they worked because
sometimes it can be hard to to visualize
these um
then this paper um i forget exactly when
when this was published uh i believe
maybe maybe the 70s um but then there
was further research into this tunnel
and more interesting other interesting
aspects about it i add those to that
paper as well there's historical context
that i also go into uh there
for instance the fact that as a as i
said that effectively after the downfall
of the roman empire no tunnels were
built like that's something that i that
i go that i that i added to the paper as
well
yeah so so this is so when other people
look at the paper
how did they usually consume the
annotations so they it's like is there a
commenting feature is uh
i mean like
this is a really enriching experience
the way you read a paper
what what aspects do you do people
usually talk about that they value from
this
so yeah so anybody can just go on there
and and either add a new annotation or
other a comment to an existing
annotation and so you can start a kind
of a thread uh within an existing
annotation um and that's something that
happens relative frequency and then
because i was the original author of the
initial annotation i get pinged and so
often times i'll go back and and
and add on to to that thread how did you
pick the paper that's i mean first of
all this whole process is really
exciting i'm gonna especially after this
conversation i'm gonna
make sure i participate much more
actively
on papers that i know a lot about and on
paper i know nothing about i shouldn't
bother when i say the paper
i would love to i also i mean i i
realized that uh there's a like it's an
opportunity for people like me
to publicly annotate a paper
like
like or do an ama around the paper like
yeah exactly
but yeah but like be um
be in the conversation about a paper
it's like a place to have a conversation
about an idea you could the other way to
do it that's much more ad hoc is on
twitter right but this is more like
formal and you could actually probably
integrate the two they have a
conversation about the conversation so
the twitter is the conversation about a
conversation and the main conversation
is in the space of annotations there's
an interesting effect that we we see
sometimes with the annotations on our
papers is that a lot of people
especially if we the annotations are
really well done people sometimes
are afraid of adding more annotations
because they see that as a kind of a
finished work yes and so they they don't
want to pollute that or
and especially if it's like a silly
question this is
i don't think that's good i think you
know
we should as much as possible try to
lower the barrier for someone to jump in
and ask questions i think it only like
most of the times it adds value but it's
some feedback that we got from users and
and readers
um
i'm not exactly sure how to
to kind of fight that but um well i
think i
i think if i serve as an inspiration
in any way
is by asking a lot of dumb questions and
saying a bunch of dumb [ __ ] all the time
and hopefully that inspires the rest of
uh other folks to do the same because
that's the only way to knowledge i think
is to
be willing to ask the dumb questions and
and there are papers that are like um
and we have a lot of papers on formats
where it's just one page or really short
papers
and you we have like the shortest paper
ever published in a math journal like
with like just a couple of words
one of my favorite papers on the
platform is actually a paper um written
by enrico fermi yeah and the title of
the paper is myop's i think it's my
observations at trinity so basically
fermi was part of the manhattan project
so he was in new mexico when um they
exploded the first atomic bomb
and so he was a couple of miles away
from the explosion and he was probably
one of the first persons to calculate
the energy of the explosion and so the
way he did that was he took a piece of
paper and he tore down a piece of paper
in little pieces and when the bomb
exploded
the trinity bomb was the name of the
bomb like he waited for the blast to
arrive at
where he was
and then he threw those pieces of paper
in the air and he calculated the energy
based on the displacement of the paper
the pieces of paper and then he wrote a
report which was classified until like a
couple of years ago one page report like
calculating the energy of the explosion
uh it's so badass and i i we actually
went there and kind of unpacked and like
yeah i think it just mentions basically
the energy and we we actually went and
one of the annotations is like
explaining how he did that
um i wonder how accurate he was
it was maybe i think like 20 20 or 25
off uh then there was another person
that actually calculated the energy
based on uh images after the explosion
at the rate uh and the rate that which
the the the like the mushroom of the
explosion expanded and it's more
accurate to calculate the energy based
on that um and i think it was like 20 20
off but it's it's really interesting
because you know fermi was known for all
these being a master at this back of the
envelope calculations always like the
the fermi problems are well known for
for that um and it's super interesting
to see like that just one page report
and was also actually classified and
it's interesting because a couple months
ago when the beirut explosion happened
there was a video circulating of these a
bride that was doing a photo shoot
when the explosion in beirut happened
and so you can see a video of her with
the wedding dress and then the explosion
happens and the blast arrives at where
she was she was a couple of miles away
from the glass and you can see like um
the displacement of the dress as well
and i actually looked and that video
went viral on twitter and i actually
looked at that video and based i used
the same techniques that fermi used to
calculate the energy of the explosion uh
based on the displacement of the dress
and you could actually see where where
she was at the the distance from the
explosion because there was a store
behind her and you could look the name
of the store and and so i calculated
that it was the distance and then you
can then based on the distance where she
was from the the explosion and also on
the the displacement of the dress like
because you can when the blast happens
like you can see the dress going back
and then
going back to the original position and
like by just looking at like how much
the the dress moved you can
estimate the explo the energy of the
explosion i assume you published this
on twitter it was just a a twitter
thread uh but it it actually like a lot
of people share that and it was picked
up by a couple of of um news outlets but
i i was hoping it would be like a formal
title and it would be an archive no no
no no maybe you submitted it just the
twitter the twitter thread but it was
interesting because it was exactly the
same method that fermi used
is there something else that jumps to
mind like what is there something
i know like in terms of papers like i
know the bitcoin paper is super popular
is there something interesting to be
said about any of the white papers in
the cryptocurrency space
yeah the
the bitcoin paper was the first paper
that we put on for mods and uh why why
that why that choice as the first paper
this was a while ago and it was one of
the papers that i read and then
and then kind of explained it to to
louisiana or to other friends that do
this journal club with us
and um
i did some research in cryptography uh
as an undergrad and so it was a topic
that i was interested in um but even for
me that i i had
that background but
reading the bitcoin paper
it took me a few weeks to really kind of
wrap my head around it it's it's right
it's it uses very spartan precise
language in a way it's like you feel
like you can't take any word out of it
without something falling apart
and uh and it's all there i think it's a
beautiful paper and it's it's it's
very well written of course but
um
you know we wanted to try to make it
accessible so that anybody that maybe is
an undergrad in computer science could
go on there and then and and know that
you have all the information
in in that page that you're going to
need to understand the mechanics of
bitcoin and so like i explain you know
the basic uh
public key cryptography that you need to
to know in order to understand it you
can explain okay what are the properties
of a hash function and how they are
useful in this context um explain what a
merkle tree is so a bunch of those basic
concepts that maybe if you're reading it
for a first time and you're an undergrad
and you know you don't know those terms
you're going to be you know discouraged
because maybe okay now i have to go and
google around until i understand these
before i can make progress in the paper
um
and and this way it's all there you know
so so there's a
magic to
also to the fact that over time more
people went on there and and added
further annotations so the idea that the
paper gets easier and more accessible
over time but that's still you're still
looking at the original content the way
the
the author
intended it to be uh but there's just
more context and the toughest bits have
have
more in-depth explanations
okay i think like there's a there's so
many interesting papers uh there like
i remember reading the paper that was
written by freeman dyson on the
like the the first time that he
explained or he came up with the concept
of the dyson sphere and he he put that
out like it's again it's one page paper
um and he what he explained was that
eventually if a civilization develops
and and grows there's going to be a
point where when the resources on the
planet are not are not enough for the
energy requirements of that civilization
so if you want to go
the next step is you need to go to the
next star and extract energy from that
star
and the way to do it is you need to
build some sort of cap around the star
that extracts the energy so he theorized
this idea of the the dyson sphere and he
went on to kind of analyze how he would
build that the stability of that sphere
like if something happens if there's
like a small oscillation with that fear
collapsing to the star or no what what
would happen and even went on to uh kind
of say that a good way for us to look
for signs of intelligent life out there
is to look for signals of these dyson
spheres
and because you know according to the
law of second law of thermodynamics like
this there's going to be some a lot of
infrared radiation that is going to be
emitted as a consequence of extracting
energy from the star and we should be
able to see those signals of like
infrared if we look at the sky but all
these like from the introduction of the
concept like the pro how to build the
dyson sphere the problems of like having
a dyson sphere how to detect how that
could be used as a signal for
intelligence like really that's all in
the paper all in one like one page paper
and it's like it's it's for me it's
beautiful it's like where was this
published i don't remember it
it's fascinating that papers like that
could be
yeah i mean the guts it takes
to put that all together in a paper you
know that that kind of challenges our
previous discussion that of paper i mean
papers can be beautiful you can play
with the format right it
but there's a lot to unpack there that's
like the the that's the the starting
point but it's it's it's beautiful that
you're able to put that in one page
and then people can build on top of that
and but the key ideas are there yeah
exactly
what about have you looked at any of the
the big seminal papers throughout the
history of science like you look at
simple like einstein papers
have any of those been annotated yeah
yeah no we we have some more seminal
papers that
that people will have heard about um you
know we have the
the dna double helix paper on there
we have the higgs boson
paper
um yeah there's papers that that we know
that it's
they're not going to be finding out
about them because of us but it's papers
that we think
should be more widely read and that
folks would benefit from having some
annotations there and so we also have a
number of those a lot of like discovery
papers for fundamental like particles
and all that there's we have a lot of
those on from us library
um yeah we i would like to end we
haven't annotated that one but i'd like
to on the riemann hypotheses that's a
really interesting paper as well um and
and but we haven't annotated that one
but there's a lot of like more
historical landmark papers
um on the platform have you done uh
point correct conjecture with uh with
perlman that's too much that's too much
that's too much too much for me but it's
uh
it's it's interesting that you know and
going back to our discussion like the
the poincare paper was like published on
archive and and it was not on a journal
like the three papers and yeah what do
you make of that i mean he's such a
fascinating human being exactly i
mentioned to you offline that i'm going
to russia he's somebody i'm
really trying to interview yeah well
so
i definitely will interview him i um and
i believe i will i believe i can i just
don't know how to
i know where you live so
here okay my my uh
my hope is my conjecture is that if i
just show up to the house and look
desperate enough
uh that uh or threatening now for some
combination of both
that like the only way to get rid of me
is to just get the thing done that's the
hope it's actually interesting that you
mentioned that because i after i um so a
couple of weeks ago i was searching for
like stuff about paramount paramount
online and ended up on this twitter
account of like this guy that claims to
be paramount perlman's assistant
and he is like he has been posting a
bunch of pictures like next to paramount
you can see like permanent in in a
library and he's like next to him like
taking a selfie or like firm and walking
on the street and like maybe you could
reach out to
this assistant then i'll send you i'll
send you this twitter account so
maybe you're on to something no but but
going back to like pheromone is super
interesting because the fact that he
published the the
the proofs on archive is what was also
like a way for him to because he really
didn't like the scientific publishing
industry and the fact that you had to
pay
to get
access to to articles and that was a
form of like protest and that's why he
published um those papers there i mean i
i think paramount is just a fascinating
like character and for me it's this kind
of ideal of a platonic ideal of what a
mathematician should be you know it's
it's someone that is you know it just
cares about deeply cares about
mathematics you know it cares about fair
attribution of um
disregards money and um
and and like the fact that he published
like on archive was is a good example of
what about the fields metal that he
turned down the fields metal what's
what's yeah
what do you make of that yeah i mean
if you look at like the reasons why he
rejected the fields medal so after so
paramount did a post talk in the us and
when he he came back to russia
um
do you know how good his english is i
think it's very fairly good it's pretty
good i think it's really good especially
given lectures in american union but i
haven't been able to listen to anything
well certainly not listen but i haven't
been able to get anybody because i know
a lot of people have been to those
lectures
i'm not able to get a sense of like
yeah but how strong is the accent what
are we talking about here is this gonna
have to be in russian is it gonna have
to be in english it's fascinating but he
writes the papers in english so it's
true like there's there's but there's so
many like such a fascinating character
and um there are a couple of examples
like him like at i think 28 or 29 he
proved like a really famous uh
conjecture called the sulk conjecture i
believe it was like in a very short
four-page proof of that it was a really
big breakthrough then he went to
princeton to give a lecture on that and
after the lecture
the the chair of the math department at
princeton a guy called peter sarnock
went up to the parliament was trying to
recruit him
trying to offer him a position at
princeton and he was and at some point
he asked for perlman's resume and
fellman responded saying just gave a
lecture on like this really tough
problem why do you need my resume like
i'm not gonna send you like i just
proved like my value
but uh but going back to the fields
metal like when when perlman went to
back to russia he
he arrived at a time where the
the salary of post docs was so much off
in regards to inflation that they were
not making any money like they
people didn't even bother to pick up the
checks at the end of the month because
it was like ridiculous but thankfully he
had some money that he had uh gained
while he was doing his post talk so he
just concentrated on like
the poincar the the prank reconjecture
problem which he when he when he took
that um it took it after it was reframed
by this mathematician called richard
hamilton which posed the problem in a
way that it turned into this super like
math olympiad problem with like perfect
boundaries well defined and that was
perfect for paramount to attack and so
he spent like seven years working on
that and then in 2002 he started
publishing those papers on archive
and
people started jumping on that reading
those papers and there was like a lot of
excitement around that a couple of years
later there were two researchers i
believe was they were from harvard that
but
took paramount pearlman's work they
sanded some of the edges and they
republished that
saying that you know
based on pearlman's work they were able
to figure out the the pronghorn
conjecture
and then there was um at the time at the
in the international um
conference of of mathematics in 2000
2006 i believe that's when they were
going to give out the fields medal there
was a lot of debate of like oh
who's who's like we should get the
credit for
solving this big problem and for
apparelmen it like it
it felt really sad that people were even
considering that he was not the person
that solved that
and and the claims that
those like researchers uh when they
published after paramount there were
false claims that they were the ones
they just sanded a couple of edges like
parliament did all the really hard work
and so
just just the fact that they doubted
that pearman had done that like was
enough for him to say i'm not i'm not
interested in this prize and that was
one of the reasons why he rejected the
fields medal it then you also rejected
the clay prize so the poincare
conjecture was one of the millennium
prices there was a million dollar prize
associated with that problem and that
has to have to do with the fact that for
them to attribute that price i think it
had to be published on a journal yes the
proof and again
paramount principles of
like interfered here and and he also
just didn't care about the money he's
like um clay i think was a businessman
and he's like doesn't have to do
anything with with mathematics i don't
care about these like um
that's one of the reasons why we
rejected that yeah there's
it's hard to convert into words but
at mit i'm
distinctly aware of the distinction
between when i enter a room there's a
certain kind of music
to the way people talk when we're
talking about ideas
versus
what that music sounds like when we're
talking
when it's like bickering
in the space of like whether it's
politics or funding
or egos
it's a different sound to it
and i'm
distinctly aware of the two
and i kind of sort of to me personally
happiness what was just like swimming
around
the one that like is the political stuff
or the money stuff and all that
uh or egos
uh
and i think that's probably what
prominent is as well like the moment he
senses there's any as with a feels
matter like the moment you start
to have any kind of drama around credit
assignment all those kinds of things
it's almost not that it's important who
gets the credit it's like the drama in
itself gets in the way of the
exploration of the ideas or the
fundamental thing that makes science
so damn beautiful and and you can really
see that there's also a product of that
russian school of like doing science
and you can see that that um
that people were you know during the
cold war a lot of mathematicians they
were not making any money they were
doing math for the sake of math
like for the intellectual
pleasure of like solving a difficult
problem yeah and you know even even if
it was a flawed system and there were a
lot of problems with with that
there's these they were able to to
actually achieve these and uh there were
a lot of imperiment for me is the
perfect product of that it just cared
about like working on tough problems he
didn't care about anything else it was
just math
you know pure math yeah there's a like
for the broader audience i think another
example of that is
like professional sports versus olympics
i've especially in russia i've seen that
clear distinction
where because the state manages
so much of the olympic process in russia
as people know the steroids yes yes yes
but outside of the steroids thing uh is
like the athlete can focus on
the pure
artistry of the sport like
like not worry about the money not just
in the way they talk about it the way
they think about it the way
they define excellence versus like
in the
perhaps a bit of a capitalist system in
united states with
american football with baseball
basketball
so much of the discussion
is about money
now of course at the end of the day it's
about excellence and artistry and all
that but
when the culture is so richly grounded
in discussions of money and
uh sort of this capitalistic like uh
merch and businesses and all those kinds
of things it changes the nature of the
activity
and it's in a way that's hard again to
describe in words but when it's purely
about the activity itself
it's almost like
you quiet down all the noise enough to
hear the signal enough to hear the
beauty like whenever you're talking
about the money that's when
the marketing people come and the
business people the non-creators come
and they fill the room and there's they
create drama and they know how to create
the drama and the noise as opposed to
people who are truly excellent at what
they do the
the person in their arena right
like when you remove all the money and
you just let
that thing shine that's when true
excellence can and can come out and that
was
of the few things that work with the
communist system the soviet union to me
at least as somebody who loves sport and
loves mathematics and uh science
that worked well removing the money from
the picture
uh
you know not that i'm um
not that i'm saying poverty is good for
science
there's some level in which not worrying
about money
is good for science it's a weird i'm not
exactly sure what to make of that
because capitalism works really damn
well yeah but
it's um
it's tricky how to find that balance one
fields metal list that is interesting to
look at and i think you mentioned it
earlier but is cedric villani which is
might be the only
uh
phil's medalist that is also a
politician now but so it's this it's
this brilliant french mathematician
that won the fields medal and and after
that he decided that
one of the ways that he could have
could have
you know the biggest leverage kind of is
in pushing science in the direction that
he thinks
science should go would be to to try to
go into politics and so that's what he
did and and uh
and the israel i'm not sure if he has
won
in any election but i think he's running
for a mayor
of paris or something like that but it's
this brilliant mathematician that
before
winning the fields medal had only been
just a brilliant mathematician but but
after that he decided to go into
politics to to try to to have an impact
and try to change some of the things
that he he would complain about before
so so there's that component
as well
yeah and i've always thought mathematics
and science should be like like james
bond
would in my eyes i think be sexier if
you did math like we should as a society
put
excellence in mathematics
at the same level as being able to kill
a man with your bare hands like those
are both useful feature like
that's admirable it's like oh like that
makes you like that makes the person
interesting
like being extremely well read about
history or philosophy being good in
mathematics being able to kill a man
with bare hands those are all the same
in my book so i think all are useful for
action stars
and i think the society will benefit for
uh for giving more value to that like
one of the things that bothers me about
american culture
is the
i don't know the right words to use but
like the nerdiness associated with
science
like
like in i i don't think nerd is a good
word in in american culture because uh
it's seen as like weakness there's like
images that come with that and it's fine
you could you could be all kinds of uh
shapes and colors and personalities but
like
to me
uh having sophisticated knowledge in
science being good at math doesn't mean
you're weak
in fact it could be the very opposite
and so it's it's an interesting thing
because it was very much differently
viewed in the uh in the soviet union so
i know for sure
as an existence proof
that it doesn't have to be that way but
it um
i also feel like we lack a lot of
like role models in terms if you ask
people like
mention
to mention one mathematician that they
know that is alive today i think a lot
of people would struggle
to answer that question um
and i also think
i love neil degrasse tyson okay
but
there is uh
having more role models is good like
different kinds of personalities he he
has kind of fun and and it's very it's
uh like
bill nye the science guy i don't know if
you guys know him so like that spectrum
that yeah but there there's not
like feynman is no longer there
uh those kinds of personalities
even carl sagan yeah
like a seriousness that's like not
playful like not apologetical yeah
exactly not apologetic about being
knowledgeable like
like
in fact like the kind of energy
where
you feel
uh self-conscious about not having
thought about some of these questions
right just like when i see james bond i
feel bad about that i don't
have never killed a man like i need to
make sure i fix that right that's the
way i feel so the same way i want to
feel like that way well carl sagan talks
i i feel like i need to have that same
kind of seriousness about science like
if i don't know something i want to i
want to know well
what about terence tao
he's kind of a superstar what are your
thoughts about him true he's probably
one of the most famous mathematicians
alive today and problem of i mean
regardless of like is of course uh
he want to feel the fields medal is
really smart and talented mathematician
um
it's also like a big inspiration for us
at least
for some of the work that we do with
formats library so terence style is is
known for having you know a big blog and
he's pretty open about
like his research and he also
he tries to make his work as public as
possible um
through his blog posts um in fact
there's a really interesting um
problem that got solved a couple of
years ago so tao was working with um on
a problem on an erdos problem actually
so if paul erdogan was this
mathematician from hungary and it was
known for like um
the airdosh
for a lot of things but one of the
things that he was also known was for
the erdos problem so he was always like
um creating these problems and usually
associating prizes with those problems
and a lot of those problems are still
open like and and there will be some of
them will be open for like maybe
a couple hundred years and i think
that's actually an interesting hack for
him to collaborate with future
mathematicians you know his his name
will will keep coming up in you know for
future generations but so tao was
working on one of these problems called
the erdog discrepancy and he published a
blog post on like
about that prop about that problem and
he reached like a dead end and then um
all of a sudden there was this guy from
from germany that wrote like a comment
on his blog post saying okay like
some of the
so this problem is like a sudoku like
flavor and some of the machinery that
we're using to solve the sudoku could be
used here and that was actually the key
to solve their those discrepancy
problems so the there was a comment on
his blog and i think that that that for
me is an example of like how to do
again going back to collaborative
science online um and the power that it
has but taw is is also like pretty
public about
uh like some of the struggles and of of
being a a mathematician like and and
even he wrote about some of the
unintended consequences of having
extraordinary ability in a field and
used himself as an example when he was
growing up he was extremely talented in
in mathematics from a young age like
todd was
a person he won an uh medal in like one
of the imo's at the age i think was a
gold medal at the age of 10 or something
like that
and so he mentioned that when he was
growing up like and especially in
college when he was in a class that he
enjoyed it didn't it just came very
natural for him and he didn't have to
work hard to just ace the class and when
he found that the class was boring like
it didn't work and he barely passed
barely passed some i think in college he
almost failed two classes
and and he was talking about that and
how he brought those studying habits or
like uh in existence of studying habits
when he went to prison princeton for his
phd and in for instance when he you know
started kind of
delving into more complex problems
and classes he struggled a lot because
he didn't have that
those those habits like it wasn't taking
notes and it was he wasn't studying hard
when he when he faced problems
and he almost failed out of his his phd
he almost failed his phd exam and um
it talks about like having this
conversation with with this advisor and
the advisor pointing out like you're not
this is not working
you might have to get out of the program
and like how that was a kind of a
turning point for him and um
and like it was super important in his
career so i think tao is also like this
figure that apart from being just an
exceptional mathematician he's also
pretty open about you know what what it
takes to to to be a mathematician and
some of the struggles of these type of
careers and and i think it's that's
super important
in many ways he's a contributor to open
science and open humanity so he's being
an open human
through by communicating uh scott
aaronson is another in computer science
world who's a very different style very
different style but there's something
about a blog that
is authentic and real and just gives us
a window into the
into the mind and soul of of of these
brilliant folks so it's it's definitely
a gift let me ask you about fermat's
library on twitter
which uh
i mean i don't know how to describe it
people should definitely just follow
from ours library on twitter
i i keep following and unfollowing for
my library because
because uh it's so
it it gives when i follow it um
leads me on down rabbit holes often that
um
that
um that are very fruitful but
but anyway so the the the posts you do
with the on twitter are just these
beautiful
are things that reveal some beautiful
aspect of mathematics
um is there
um is there something you could say
about the approach there yeah
and um
maybe
maybe broadly what you find beautiful
about mathematics and then more
specifically how
you convert that into a rigorous process
of revealing that in tweet form that's a
good point i think there's something
about math that you know a lot of the
mathematical content and you know paper
papers are like little proofs
um you know
has
in a way sort of an infinite half-life
what i mean by that is that if you look
at like euclid's elements it's as valid
today as it was when it was created like
2 000 years ago and that's not true for
a lot of other scientific fields
um
and so
in regards to twitter i think
there's also a very it's a very undex
underexplored platform from a learning
perspective
i think if you look at content on
twitter it's very easy to consume it's
very easy to read
um
and especially when you're
trying to explain something you know we
humans get a dopamine hit if we learn
something new
and that's a very very powerful feeling
and that's why you know people go to
classes when you have a really good
professor you know it's it's looking for
those dopamine hits and
and and
and that's something that we try to
explore when we're producing content on
twitter imagine if we we could
if you would on a line to a restaurant
you could go go to your phone to learn
something new instead of social
going to a
you know social network to just and so
and i think
it's very hard to to sometimes to
kind of provide that feeling because you
need to
sometimes digest content and and put it
in a way you know that it feeds 280
characters um
and and it requires a lot of
sometimes time to do that even though
it's easy to consume it's hard to make
but once you are able to to provide that
eureka moment to people
like that's very powerful they get that
dopamine hit and like you create this
feedback cycle and people come back for
for more and in twitter compared to like
you know an online course for a book you
have a zero percent dropout so people
will will read the content the content
so that it's it's like it's part of the
creators like the person that is
creating the content if you're able to
actually get that feedback cycle it's
super super powerful
yeah but some of the stuff is like like
how the heck do you find that and and i
don't know why it's so appealing it uh
like
uh this is from uh what is it
a couple days ago
i'll just read out the number two three
four five six seven eight nine is the
largest prime number with consecutive
increasing digits
i mean
that is so cool that's like some weird
like glimpse
into some deep universal truth
even though it's just a number
i mean that's like so arbitrary like why
why is it so pleasant that that's a
thing but it is in some way it's almost
like it is a little glimpse at some
much bigger
like um and and i think like especially
if we're talking about science there's
something unique
about you go and with a lot of the
tweets you go sometimes from a state of
not knowing something to knowing
something
and that is very particular to science
science math physics and that again is
extra extremely addictive and that's
that's how i i i feel about that and um
that's why i think people engage so much
with with our tweets and go into rabbit
holes and then they you know we start
with prime numbers and all of a sudden
you are spending hours reading number
theory
things and you go into wikipedia and you
lose a lot of time there but
well the variety is really interesting
too there's human things there's uh
there's physics things
there's like numeric things like like i
just mentioned but there's also
more rigorous mathematical things
there's stuff that's tied to the history
of math and the proofs and
this visual there's animations
that are looping animations that are
incredible that reveal something
there's uh
andrew wiles i'm being smart and this is
just me now like
ignoring you guys and just going through
oh yeah we're a bit like math drug
dealers we're just trying to get you
hooked you know we're trying to give you
that hit and trying to get you hooked
yes some people are brighter than others
but i really believe that most people
can really get
to to quite a good level of mathematics
if they're prepared to deal with these
psychological issues of how to handle
the situation of being stuck yeah yeah
there's some truth to that that's truth
i feel that's like really
it's some truth in terms of research and
also about startups you're they're stuck
a lot of the time
before you you get to a breakthrough and
and it's difficult to endure that
process of like being stuck and because
you're not trying to to be in that
position um i feel uh yeah that's
yeah most people are broken by the
stuckness or like they're destroy like
uh
i i've i've been very cognizant of the
fact that
more and more social media becomes a
thing
like distractions become a thing that
that moment of being stuck
is uh your mind wants to to go do stuff
that's unrelated to being stuck and
you should be stuck i'm referring to
small stucknesses
like
you're like trying to design something
and it's a dead end basically little
dead ends
on dead ends and programming dead ends
and trying to think through something
and then your mind wants to like
like
like uh this is the problem with this
work-life balance culture is like
take a break like as if taking a break
will solve everything sometimes it
solves quite a bit but like sometimes
you need to sit in a stuckness and
suffer a little bit and then take a
break
but you you definitely need to be
and like most people quit
from that psychological battle of being
stuck and so success is people who
who who uh persevere through that yeah
yeah and and in the creative process
that's also true i was the other day i
was i think was reading about is this um
what is his name ed sheeran like the
musician yeah was talking a little bit
about the creative process and using was
using this analogy of a faucet like
where you when you turn on a faucet as
like the dirty water coming out in the
beginning
and you just have to you know keep
trusting that at some point your clean
clean clear water will come out but you
have to endure that process like in the
beginning it's going to be dirty water
and and and just you know
embrace that yeah actually this uh the
entirety of my youtube channel and this
podcast have been following that
philosophy of dirty water
like i've been you know
i do believe that like you have to get
all the crap out of your system first
and uh sometimes it's it's all
sometimes it's all crappy work
i mean i tend to be very self-critical
but i do
think that quantity leads to quality for
some people it does for my the way my
mind works is like just keep
putting stuff out there keep creating
and uh
the quality will come as opposed to
sitting there waiting
not doing anything until
the thing seems perfect because the
perfect may never come
but just just on like on on our twitter
like profile i really and sometimes when
you look on some of those tweets they
might seem like pretty
kind of
um you know why is this interesting it's
like so raw uh like it's just a number
but i really believe that especially
with math or physics
it is possible to get everyone to love
math or physics even if you think you
hate it it's it's not a function of the
student or the person that is on the
other side i think is just purely a
function of like how you explain uh
hidden beauty that they hadn't realized
before
it's not easy but i think it's like a
lot of the times it's on like on the
creator's side to to be able to like
show that beauty to the other person i
think some of that is native to to
humans we just have that curiosity and
you look at small toddlers and babies
and like them trying to figure things
out and there's just something that is
born with us that we we we want for that
understanding we want to figure out the
world around us and and so
yeah it shouldn't be like uh whether or
not people are going are going to to
enjoy it like
i i i also really believe that everybody
has that capacity to fall in love with
with math and physics
you mentioned startup
what do you think it takes to build a
successful startup yeah that
it's what what louise was saying that um
you need to in to be able to endure
being stuck and and i think
the best way to put it is that startups
don't have
a linear reward function
right you oftentimes don't get rewarded
for effort and and
in most of our lives we go through
these processes that
do
give you those small rewards for effort
right in school you study hard generally
you'll get a good grade and then you
good you get like good grades ever or
you get grades every semester and so
you're you're slowly
getting rewarded and pushed in the right
direction
for for startups and startups are not
the only thing that is like this but for
startups it's you know you can put in a
ton of effort into something
that and then get no reward for it right
it's like like sisyphus boulder where
you're pushing that boulder up the
mountain
and and and you get to the top and then
it just rolls all the way back down
and and so that's something that i think
a lot of people are not equipped to deal
with and can be incredibly demoralizing
especially if that happens more than
than a few times
and so but i think it's absolutely
essential to to power through it because
uh by the nature of startups it's often
times you know you're dealing with with
with non-obvious ideas and things that
there might be contrarian and so you're
gonna you're gonna run into into that a
lot you're gonna do things that are not
gonna work out uh and you need to be
prepared to deal with that but
but we're not coming out of college
you're you're just not equipped i'm not
sure if there's a way to train people to
deal with those non-linear reward
functions but it's definitely i think
one of the most difficult things to you
know
about doing a startup and also happens
in research sometimes you know we're
talking about the default studies being
stuck you just you know you don't like
you try things you get zero results you
close doors you constantly closing doors
until you you know find something and um
yeah that is a big thing
what about sort of this point when
you're stuck
there's a kind of decision whether you
if you have a vision
to persist through through with this
direction that you've been going along
or what a lot of startups do or
businesses is pivot
how do you decide whether like
to give up
on a particular flavor of the way you've
imagined the design and to like adjust
it or completely
like alter it i think that's a core
question for startups that i've asked
myself exactly and like i've never been
able to come up with a great framework
to make those decisions um i think
that's really at the core of
uh yeah out of a lot of the the toughest
questions that
that people that's that started a
company have to deal with um
i think maybe the best framework that i
i
was able to figure out like when you run
out of ideas you just you know you're
exploring something it's not working you
try it in a different angle you know you
try a different business model yeah when
you run out of ideas like you don't have
any more cards just
switch and yeah
it's not perfect
because you also it's you have a lot of
stories of startups with like
people kept pushing and then you know
that paid off
and then you have uh philosophies
there's like fail fast and pivot fast um
so it's
you know it's hard to you know balance
these two worlds and understand what is
the best framework
and i mean if you look at four miles
library your
maybe you can correct me but it feels
like you're an operating in a space
where there's a lot of things that are
broken
and or could be significantly improved
so it feels like there's a lot of
possibilities for pivoting
or like how do you revolutionize science
how do you revolutionize
the aggregation the
the annotation the commenting the
community around information about
knowledge structured knowledge i mean
that's kind of what like stack overflow
and stack exchange has struggled with
to come up with a solution and they've
come up i think with an interesting set
of solutions that are also i think
flawed in some ways but they're much
much better than the alternatives
but there's a lot of other possibilities
if we just look at papers as we talked
about there's so many possible
revolutions and they're a lot of money
to be potentially made in those
revolutions plus coupled with that the
benefit to humanity
and so like you're sitting there
like i don't know how many people are
legitimately from a business perspective
playing with these ideas it feels like
there's a lot of ideas here true there
is are you right now grinding in a
particular direction like is there a
like a five-year vision that you're
thinking in your mind
for us it's more like a 20-year vision
in the sense that uh we we've
consciously tried to make the decision
of
so we so we run fermat says it's a side
project and it's a separate in the sense
like it's not what we're working on
full-time
and uh
but
our thesis there is that
we actually think that it's that's a
good thing at least for for this stage
of vermont's library um and also because
some of these projects
you just
if you're coming from a start from a
startup framework you probably try to
try to fit every single idea into
something that can change the world
within three to five years and there's
just some problems that take longer than
that right and so you know we're talking
about archive and i'm very doubtful that
you could grow
like archive into what it is today like
within two or three years no matter how
much money you throw at it there's just
some things that can take longer but you
need to be able to power through
the the the time that it takes um but if
you look at it as okay this is a company
this is a startup we have to grow fast
we have to raise money then uh
then sometimes you might forgo those
ideas because of that um because they
don't very well fit into the
the typical
startup framework and so for us formats
it's something that we're okay with
growing with having it grow slowly and
and maybe taking many years and and and
that's why we think it's it's not a bad
thing that it is a side project because
it makes it much more
um
acceptable in a way and that to to to be
able to be okay with that that said i
think what happens is
if you keep pushing new little features
new little ideas i feel like there's
like certain ideas will just become
viral
like and then you just won't be able to
help yourself but it'll revolutionize
things it feels like there needs to be
that needs to be but there's um
opportunity for viral ideas to change
science absolutely
and maybe we don't know what those are
yet it might be a very small kind of
thing maybe you don't even know if
should this be a for-profit company
that's the wikipedia question yeah um
is that a lot of questions like really
fundamental questions about this space
that we've we've talked about i mean you
take wikipedia and you try to run it as
a startup and by now we'd have a paywall
you'd be paying 9.99 a month to to read
more than 24 i mean that's that's one
view yeah the other
the ad driven model so they rejected the
ad driven model
i don't know if we could i mean this is
a difficult question
you know if archive was supported by ads
i don't know if that's bad for archive
if vermont's library was supported by
ads i don't know i don't
i'm not it's not trivial to me i'm
unlike i think a lot of people
uh i'm not against advertisements i
think as when done well are really good
i think the problem with facebook and
all the social networks are the way
the lack of transparency around the way
they use data
and
the lack of control the users have over
their data and not the fact that data is
being collected and used to sell
advertisements it's a lack of
transparency lack of control if you if
you do a good job of that i feel like
it's really nice way to make stuff free
yeah for example it's like stack
overflow right yeah
i think they've done an okay a good job
with that even though as we said like
they're capturing very little of the
value that they're putting out there
right but but it makes it a sustainable
company and and they're providing a lot
of it's a fantastic and very productive
community let me ask a
a ridiculous tangent of a question where
he's you wrote a paper on a on game of
thrones battle of winterfell just
as a side little i i'm sorry i noticed
i'm sure you've done a lot of ridiculous
stuff like this i just noticed that
particular one
by ridiculous i mean you're ridiculously
awesome can you describe the the
approach in this work which i believe is
a legitimate publication
so going back to the original like uh
when we were talking about the backstory
of of papers and the importance of that
so this is actually you know it was
when the last season of the the show was
airing uh this was a during a company
lunch
we there was in in the last season
there's the
there's a really big battle against the
the forces of evil and the you know
forces of good and this is called the
battle of winterfell
and um
in this battle there are like these two
armies and there's a very particular
thing that they have to take into
account is that in the army of dead like
if someone dies in the army of the
living like that person is gonna you
know be a reborn as
a soldier in the army of the dead yes
and so that was an important thing to
take into account and the initial
conditions as you specify it's about a
hundred thousand on each side exactly so
i was able i was able to like based on
some images like on previous episodes to
figure out what was the size of the
armies and so what i want what we wanted
to do what we were theorizing was like
how many soldiers does like a a soldier
on the army of the living has to kill
in order for them to be able to this to
destroy the army of the dead without
like
losing because every time
one of the good soldiers died is going
to turn into like the other side and so
it's so i we we were theorizing that and
and i wrote a couple of uh differential
equations and um i was able to figure
out that based on the size of the armies
i think i think was the ratio had to be
like 1.7 so it had to kill like 1.7 um
soldiers like the army of the dead in
order for them to win the battle
well yeah that's that's science it is
it's it's
most powerful
and this is also somehow a pitch
for uh like a hiring pitch in a sense
like this is the kind of uh yeah before
the science you do it exactly yeah
well turned out to be you know as as is
for people that have watched these shows
is like they know that every time you
try to predict something that is going
to happen it's going to you're going to
fail miserably and that's what happened
so it was not not at all important
for the show but yeah we ended up like
putting that out and there was a lot of
people that shared that i think was some
like elements of the of the show the
cast of the show that actually retweeted
that and shared that at first so it was
fun i would love if this kind of
calculation happened uh like during the
making of the show or the you know i
love it
like in um
for example i now know um alex garland
the director of ex machina
and i love it
he doesn't seem to be
some
not many people seem to do this but i
love it when directors
and people who wrote the story
really think through the technical
details
like whether it's knowing like how
things even if it's science fiction
if you were to try to do this how would
you do this like stephen wolfram and his
son were
were collaborating with the movie
arrival in designing the alien language
how you communicate with aliens like how
would you really have
a math-based language that uh that could
span the alien
and uh being and the human
being so i i love it when they have that
kind of regular the martian was also big
on that like the book in the movie was
all about like can we actually
is this plausible can these happen it
was all about that and that can really
bring you in like the sometimes the
small details uh i mean the guy that
wrote the martian book is another book
that is also filled with those like
things that when you realize that okay
these are grounded in in science can
just really bring you in yeah right like
there's a book about a colony on the
colony on the moon and he goes about
like all the details that would you know
be required about setting up a colony in
the moon and like things that he
wouldn't think about like the the fact
that um they would you know it's hard to
bring like uh air to the moon say so
they wouldn't like how do you make that
breathable that environment breathable
you need to bring oxygen but like you
you you probably wouldn't be bring
nitrogen so what you do is like instead
of having a an
atmosphere that is 100
oxygen you like decrease the pressure so
that you have the same ratio of oxygen
on earth but like lowering the pressure
here and so like things like water boils
at the lower temperature so people would
would have coffee and the coffee would
be colder like there was a problem in
this uh environment in the moon so like
and these are like small things in the
book
but
i studied physics so like when i read
this i that throws me into like
a tangents and i start researching that
and it's like i really like to read
books and and watch movies when they go
to that level of detail
uh uh about science yeah i think
interstellar was one where they also
consulted heavily with with the number
of yeah i think even resulted in a
couple of papers a couple papers about
like the black hole uh visualizations
and um
yeah but there's and there's even more
examples of interesting science around
like these fantasy
we were reading at some point like these
guys that were uh trying to figure out
if if the tolkien's middle earth if it
was uh round if it was like a sphere if
it was like
based on the map and some of the
references in the
in the books and so uh yeah we actually
i think we tweeted about that
yeah we did based on the distance
between the cities you can actually
prove that that could be like a map of a
sphere or like a spheroid and and you
can actually calculate the radius of
that planet
uh
that's fascinating
i mean yeah that's fascinating but
there's something about like calculating
the number
like
exactly the calculation you did for for
the battle winterfell is um
there's something fascinating about that
because it's not like being
that's very mathematical versus like
grounded in physics
and that's really interesting i mean
that's like injecting mathematics into
fantasy
there's there's something um i see
magical about that and and that for me
that's why i think it's also when you
look at things like
like uh fermat's last theorem like
problems that are very kind of
self-contained and simple to state yeah
i think like
that's the same with that paper it's
very easy to understand the boundaries
of the problem you know
um and and that for me that's why those
and that's why math is so appealing and
those like problems are also so
appealing to the general public it's not
that they look simple or that people
think that they're easy to like solve
but i feel that a lot of the times they
are
almost intellectually democratic because
everyone
understands the starting point you know
you look at fermat's last theorem
everyone understands like is the this is
the the universe of the problem and the
same maybe with that paper everyone
understands okay these are the starting
conditions
and um
and and yeah that the fact that it
becomes intellectually democrat and i
think that's a huge motivation
for people and that's why
so so many people gravitate towards
these like riemann hypotheses or
vermont's last theorem or that simple
paper which is like just one page it's
very simple
and i just talked to somebody i don't
know if you know who he is jaco willink
who is uh
this person
who among many things loves military
tactics so
he would probably either publish
a follow-on paper maybe you guys should
collaborate but he would see the
fundament the basic assumptions that he
started that paper with is flawed
because you know there's like dragons
too right there's like
like you have to integrate tactics
because not it's not it's not a
homogeneous system
it's not you i don't take into account
the dragons and like and he would say
tactics fundamentally change the
dynamics of the system
and so like
that's what happened
so uh yeah so at least from a scientific
perspective he was right but he never
published so there you go
uh let me ask the most important
question you guys are from
portugal both yeah
so
who is the greatest soccer player
footballer of all time
yeah i think we're a little bit biased
on this topic but uh i mean i have
maradona
i i have a huge i have a you know
tremendous respect for for what um here
we go
this is the political issue
we can convince you i i i mean i have
tremendous respect for what ronaldo has
achieved in in his career and and i
think soccer is one of those sports
where i think you can get to maybe be
one of the best players in the world
we
if you just have like natural talent and
even if you don't put a lot of hard work
and discipline into soccer you can be
one of the best players in the world and
i think ronaldo is kind of like of
course he's naturally talented but yeah
exactly from portugal um and and not uh
not the brazilian in this case and so um
and ronaldo put like came from nothing
he he's known from being probably one of
the hardest working athletes in the game
and and i see that sometimes a lot of
these discussions about the best player
a lot of people train tend to gravitate
towards like um you know this person is
naturally talented and the other person
has to work hard and so and so as if it
was bad if he had to work hard to to be
good at something and i think that you
know the the
i think so many people fall into that
trap and the reason why so many people
fall into that trap is because if you
are saying that someone
is good and achieved a lot of success by
working hard as opposed to achieving
success because it has some sort of
god-given natural talent then you can't
explain why the person was born with
that
what does it tell you about you
it tells you that maybe if you work hard
on a lot of fields you could have
could accomplish a lot of great things
and i think that's hard to digest for a
lot of people
and and that way ronaldo's inspiring
that i think so you find hard work
that's probably but he's he's way too
good looking that's nice
you know that's the yeah i don't like
him probably no i like the part of the
hard work and like of him being like one
of the hardest working athletes in in
soccer
so he is to you the greatest of all time
is he up there is he would be number one
okay
do you agree with this thing oh hardly
disagree well i definitely disagree i
mean i i like him very much he works
hard i admire
i admire you know um
would like he's an incredible uh
a goal scorer right
um
but
i
so first of all
leo messi and there was some confusion
because i've kept saying maradona is my
favorite player but i i think
i think leo has surpassed them
so uh
um it's messy that mardonna then
pele for me but the the reason is is um
there's certain
aesthetic definitions of beauty that i
admire whether it came by hard work or
through god-given talent or through
anything and it doesn't it doesn't
really matter to me there's certain
aesthetic
like genius when i when i see it to me
and uh especially it doesn't have to be
consistent it is in the case of messi in
a case in the ronaldo but just even
moments of genius which is where
maradona really shines it i
even if that doesn't translate into like
results and goals being scored right
right and that's the challenge like they
did that
because that's where people that tell me
that leo messi's never
even on strong teams have led his
the national team people as part of the
world cup right as really important and
to me no it's the moment like winning to
me was never important
what's more important is the moments of
genius and
but you're you're talking to the human
story
and
um
yeah cristiano ronaldo definitely has a
beautiful human story yeah and i think
you can't i for me it's hard to decouple
those two um i i don't i don't just look
at you know the the list of achievements
but i like how he got there and how he
keeps pushing the boundaries at like
almost 40 yeah and how that sets up an
example like maybe 10 years ago i
wouldn't have ever imagined that like
one of the top players in the world
could be a top player at like 37 or but
so and there's an interesting ten the
human story is really important but like
if you look at ronaldo he's like he's
somebody like kids could aspire to be
but at the same time i also like
maradona who like is a as a tragic
figure in many ways it's like the you
know the drugs the the temper all of
those things that's beautiful too like i
don't
necessarily think to me
the flaws are beautiful too in in
athletes i don't think
you need to be perfect i agree uh from a
personality perspective those flaws
are also beautiful so but yeah there is
something about
hard work
and uh there's also something about the
being an underdog and being able to
carry a team
uh that's that's an argument from
maradona i don't know if you can make
that argument for messi and ronaldo
either because they've all played on
superstar teams for most of their lives
so i don't know
how it you know it's it's difficult to
know how they would do
um
when they had to work
like did what mardonna had to do to
carry a team on his shoulders true
and pele did as well and so depending on
the the context yeah maybe you could
argue that within portuguese national
team but they were we have a good team
uh yeah but maybe with what maradona did
with you know
naples and and a couple other teams it's
it seemed incredible this is the beauty
of the game that you know we're talking
about all these different players that
have
or especially you know if you're
comparing messi and ronaldo that have
such different you know styles of play
and also even
their bodies are so different and and
and but
these two
very different players can be at the top
of the game and that's not that's the
they're not a lot of other sports where
you where you have that you know like
you have kind of a mental image of a
basketball player and like the the top
basketball players kind of fit that
mental image and and they look a certain
way
and um
but for soccer there's so there's
it's it's not so much like that and and
that's i think that's that's beautiful
uh but that's that really adds something
to the sport
well do you play soccer yourself have
you played that in your life what do you
find beautiful about the game yeah i
mean it's one of the i'd say it's the
biggest sport in portugal and so growing
up we played a lot did you see the paper
from deepmind i didn't look at it where
they're like uh doing some uh analysis
on soccer strategy yeah interesting i
saved that paper uh i haven't read it
yet um it's actually i i when i was in
college i actually did some
research on on applying um
machine learning and statistics in
sports and in our ca in our case we're
doing it for basketball
but uh
what they're effectively trying to do
was
have you ever watched moneyball like
yeah so they're trying to do something
similar to
taking that in this case basketball
taking a statistical approach to
to to basketball um
the interesting thing there is that
baseball is much more about having these
discrete events that happen kind of in
similar conditions and so it's easier to
take a statistical approach to it
whereas basketball is a much more
dynamic game
it's harder to measure
um
it's hard to to replicate these
conditions and so
you you have to think about it in a
slightly different way and so we were
doing work on that and working like with
the celtics to analyze the the the data
that they had like they had these
cameras in the in the arena they were
tracking the players and so you so they
have they had a ton of data but they
didn't really know what to do with it
and so we were doing work on that and
and and soccer is maybe an even a step
further it's it's right it's a game
where you don't have as many
in in basketball you have a lot of field
goals and so you can measure success uh
soccer it's it's right it's more of a
poisson process almost where it's like
you have a goal like or two and again in
terms of metrics i wonder if there's a
way and i've actually have thought about
this in the past never coming up with
any good solution if there's a way to
definitively say whether it's messier
and now they're the greatest of all time
like honestly sort of measure
interesting
like convert the game of soccer into
metrics like you said baseball but like
those moments of genius like pat like um
you know if it's just about goals or
passes that led to goals that feels like
it doesn't capture the genius of them
yeah they'll be like you know like
like you kind of do you have more
metrics for instance in chess right and
you can try to understand how hard of a
move
there was you know there's like bobby
fischer has this move that like
that it's i think it's called the move
of the century where uh
you have to go so deep into the tree to
understand that that was the right move
and you can quantify it how hard it was
so it'd be interesting to try to think
of those type of metrics but say yeah
for soccer computer vision unlocks some
of that for us that's that's one
possibility i have a cool idea a
computer vision product likes that you
could build for soccer
i'm taking notes
if you could detect the ball and like
imagine that um this seems like totally
doable right now but like if you could
detect when the ball enters one of the
goals and like just had like um you know
a crowd cheering for you when you're
playing soccer with your friends every
time you score a goal or you had like
the the champions league song going on
yeah and like having that like you go
play soccer with your friends you just
turn that on and there's like a computer
vision like program analyzes the ball
detects the ball every time there's a
goal like if you miss like there's a you
know the fans are reacting to that and
then
it should be pretty simple by now it's
like i think there's an opportunity
there so yeah just throwing that i would
go all out but by the way i did uh i've
never released i was thinking of just
putting on github but i did write
exactly that which is the trackers for
the players
uh for the for the bodies of the player
it's this is the hard part actually
the detection of player bodies and the
ball is not hard what's hard is
very like robust tracking through time
of each of those
so like so i wrote a track of this
pretty damn good this is this is that is
that open source
i know i've never released it because
that's interesting because i thought
like
i need to i would
this is the perfection thing because i
knew it was going to be like
it's going to pull me in and and it
wasn't really that done
and so i've never actually been part of
a github project where it's like really
active development and i didn't want to
make it i knew there's a non-zero
probability that will become my life for
like a half a year
that's uh just how much i love soccer
and all those kinds of things and and
ultimately it will be all for just the
the joy
of analyzing the game which i'm all for
i remember you also like one of in one
of the episodes you mentioned that you
did also a lot of eye tracking analysis
like joe rogan's that was the that was
the research side of my life interesting
yeah and you have that library right you
you kind of downloaded all the episodes
yep allegedly i and of course i didn't
if you're a lawyer listening to this no
it is i i was listening to the episode
where you mentioned that and i was
actually there was something that i and
i might ask you for for access to that
to allegedly that library uh but i was
doing some not not regarding like eye
tracking but i was
playing around with um analyzing the
distribution of silences on uh one of
the joe rogan episodes so like i did
that for the elon
conversation where it's like you just
take all the silences
like after joe asked the question and
elon responded and you plot that
distribution and like and see how
how that looks like yeah i think there's
a huge opportunity especially long-form
podcasts
to do that kind of analysis bigger than
joe exactly but it has to be a fairly
unedited podcasts so that you don't cut
the silence so one of the benefits i
have like doing this podcast is like the
the what we're recording today is
there's
individual audio
being recorded
like i have the raw information no it's
when it's published it's all combined
together and individual video feeds so
even when you're listening which i
usually don't i only show one video
stream
i i'll know i can track your blinks and
so on
um but yeah but ultimately the hope is
you don't need that raw data because if
you don't need the raw data for whatever
analysis you're doing
you can then do a huge number of
products because there's so it's quickly
growing now the number especially
comedians
there's uh quite a few comedians with
with long-form podcasts
and
they have a lot of facial expressions
they have a lot of fun and all those
kinds of things and it's it's prone for
analysis yeah and it's there's so many
interesting things that
that that idea actually sparked because
i was watching a
um
a q a by by steve jobs and i think was
at mit and then like people's like he
did a talk there and then
the q and a started and people started
asking questions that i was i was
working while listening to it and like
someone asked the question and he goes
like on a 20-second silence before
answering the question i like i had to
check if the if the video hadn't paused
or something
and and i was thinking about like like
if that is a feature of a person like
how long on average you take to respond
to a question and if it's like that's
fascinating it has to do with it like
how thoughtful you are and if that
changes over time well but it also could
be this really fascinating metric
because it also could be
it's certainly a feature of a person but
it's also a function of the question
like if you normalize to the person
you can probably infer a bunch of stuff
about the question so it's a nice flag
like it's a really strong signal the
length of that silence
relative to the usual silence they have
so one the silence is a measure of how
thoughtful they are and two the
particular sounds doesn't measure how
thoughtful the question was thoughtful
the question was it's really interesting
i mean yeah yeah i just analyzed elon's
uh um
episode but i think there's like room
for exploration there i feel like the
average they could do for comedians
would be
like i mean the time would be so small
because you're trained to like i would
think you're reacting to hecklers you're
reacting to all sorts of things you have
to be like so quick maybe right yeah but
some of the greatest comedians are very
good at sitting in the silence i mean
there there's lucy kaye
they played with that
because you have a rhythm and you like
um
dave chappelle a comedian who did uh
joe's show recently
he has uh
especially when he's just having a
conversation
he does long pauses it's kind of cool
because it uh
it's one of the ways to have people hang
in your word is to play with the pauses
to play with the silences and the
emphasis
and like mid-sentence there's a bunch of
different things that uh it'd be
interesting to really
really analyze but still soccer to me is
uh that's that that one that's
fascinating just i just want a
conclusive definitive statement about
it's like there are so many
soccer highlights of both messi and
ronaldo
i just feel like the raw data is there
um because you don't have that with pele
just remember yeah through but here's a
huge amount of high def data then the
the annoying the difficult thing and
this is really hard for tracking and
this is actually where i kind of gave up
because i didn't really give much effort
but i gave up
to the the way that highlights or
usually football match are filmed is
they switch the camera so they'll
they'll do a different switch
perspective so you have to
it's a really interesting computer
vision problem when the perspective is
switched you still have a lot of overlap
about the players but the perspective is
sufficiently different that you have to
like recompute everything so i
there there's two ways to solve this so
one
is doing it the full way where you're
constantly doing the slam problem you
you're doing a 3d reconstruction the
whole time and projecting into that 3d
world
but you could also there could be some
hex
that i wonder like some trick where you
can hop
like when the perspective shifts
do a high probability tracking hops from
one object to another but i i thought
especially in exciting moments when when
uh
when you're passing players like you're
doing a single ball dribble
across players and you switch
perspective which is when they often do
when you're making a run on goal if you
switch your perspective
it's it feels like that's going to be
really tricky to get right
automatically but in that case i feel
like if somebody released that data set
or it's like you just have all like
these this data set a massive data set
of all these games from from say ronaldo
and messi like and just you just add
that in like whatever csv format and
some some publicly available data set
like that i feel like people would just
there there would be so many cool things
that you could do with it and you just
set it free and then like the world
would like do its thing and then like
interesting things would come out of it
by the way
i have this data set so
the two things that i've did of this
scale
uh is soccer so it's body pose and ball
tracking for soccer and then um i tr
it's
pupil tracking and blink tracking for
it was joe rogan and a few other
podcasts that i did so those are the two
data sets i have
did you analyze any of your podcasts
no i i think i really started doing this
podcast after
after doing that work and it's difficult
to
maybe i'd be afraid of what i find
i'm already annoyed with my own voice
and video like editing it
but perhaps that's the honest thing to
do because uh one useful thing
about doing computer vision about myself
is like i know what i was thinking at
the time so you can start to like
connect the particular
the behavioral peculiarities of like the
way you blink the way you squint
the way you
close your eyes like
talking about details there's it's like
for example i just closed my eyes
is that a blink or no
like
figuring that out in terms of timing in
terms of the blink dynamics
is tricky it's very doable i
i think there's universal laws
about what is a blink and what is a
closed eye and all those things plus
makeup and eyelashes i actually um
have annoyingly long eyelashes so i
remember when i was doing a lot of this
work i i would cut off my eyelashes
when like especially it was funny like
female colleagues were like what the
[ __ ] are you doing like those no keep
the eyelashes but because it got in the
way made the computer vision a lot more
difficult but
super interesting topics yeah but
speaking about the
one uh still on the topic of the data
sets for sports there's one um one paper
that and i actually annotated it on
fermat and uh
it's it was published in uh 90s 90s i
believe 90s or 80s i forget but they're
you the researcher was effectively
looking at
the hot and phenomena in basketball
right so whether like the fact that you
just made a field goal um if you know if
on your next attempt if you're more
likely to make it or not
um
and it was super interesting because i
mean he pulled like i think 100
undergrads and
i think from stanford and cornell and
asking people like do you
you think that's that you have a higher
likelihood of making your free throw if
you just just made one and i think it's
like 68 68
said yes they believe that and and then
he looked
at the data
and this was back in as i said like a
few decades ago and so i think he had a
data set of about
he looked at it specifically for free
throws and he had a data set of about 5
000 free throws
and
and effectively what he found was that
specifically in the case of free throws
he didn't for the aggregate data he
didn't find um that
he couldn't really spot that correlation
that hot end correlation so if you made
the first one you weren't more likely to
to make the second one what he did find
was that they were just better at the
second one because you just got like
maybe a tiny practice and you just you
attempted once and then and then you're
going to be better at the next one and
then i i then i went and there's a data
set on kaggle that has like 600 000 free
throws and i reran the the same
computations and and
confirmed like you can see a very clear
pattern that they're just better at
their second free throw um that's
interesting because i think there's
similar
that kind of analysis is so awesome
because i think with tennis they have
like uh like a fault like when you serve
they have analysis of like are you most
likely to miss the second serve if you
missed first obviously
um yeah i think that's the case so that
integrates
that's so cool when psychology is
converted into metrics in that way and
in sports it's especially cool because
it's such a constrained system that you
can really study human psychology
because it's repeated it's constrained
so many things are controlled which is
something you rarely have in
in the wild psychological experiment so
it's cool
uh plus everyone loves it like sports is
really cool to analyze
people actually care about the results
yeah um i still think well like i yeah
and i will definitely publish uh this
work on messi versus ronaldo and i'd
love to read it objective fully
objective to peer review
um yeah this is very true this is not
past peer review
um let me ask sort of um
an advice question
to uh to young folks
you've explored a lot of fascinating
ideas in your life
you've built a startup
worked on physics worked in computer
science
what advice would you give to young
people today in high school maybe early
college about life about career
about science and mathematics
i remember like i
i read like i remember reading that um
ponkario was once asked by um
a french journal about his advice for
young people and what was his teaching
philosophy and he said that like one of
the most important things that parents
should teach their kids is how to be
enthusiastic
um
in regards to like the mysteries of the
world
and that he said like striking that
balance was actually one of the most
important things between like in
education you know you want to
have your kids be enthusiastic about the
mysteries of the world but you also
don't want to traumatize them like if
you really force them into something and
i think like especially
if you're young i think you
you should be curious and i think you
should ex
explore that curiosity to the fullest to
the point where you even become almost
as an expert on that topic
and now and
you might start with something that it's
small like you might start with you know
you're interested in numbers and how to
factor numbers into primes and then all
of a sudden you go and and you're like
lost in number theory and you discover
cryptography and then all of a sudden
you're buying bitcoin
and i and i think you should do these um
you should really try to fulfill this
curiosity and you should live in a
society that allows you to fulfill this
curiosity which is also important and i
think you should do these not to get to
some sort of status or fame or money but
i think this is the way this iterative
process i think this is the way to find
happiness
and
and i think this is also allows you to
find the meaning for your life
i think it's all about like being
curious and being able to fulfill that
curiosity and that path
to fulfilling that uh your curiosity
yeah the the the start small and let the
fire build is kind of interesting way to
think about it and you never know where
you're gonna end up it's it's
like for instance from us it's just a
really good example we started like just
by doing this as an internal like thing
that we did with in the company and then
we started putting out there and now a
lot of people follow it and know about
it and so um and you still don't know
where females libra is going to end up
actually true exactly so um yeah i think
that would be my
piece of advice with very limited
experience of course but yeah yeah i
agree i agree
uh i mean is there something in from
particular
journal from the computer science versus
physics perspective
uh do do you regret not doing physics do
you regret not doing computer science
which one is the the wiser the better
human being this is messy versus ronaldo
those are very
i i don't know if you would agree but
they're kind of different disciplines
true yeah
very much so
um i actually actually uh
i was i i had that question in my mind i
i took physics classes uh as an
undergrad uh or like
besides what i had to take
and um
it's definitely something that i
considered at some point
um
and
and that that i
i i do feel like later in life that
might be something that
i'm not sure if regret is
is the right word but it's it's kind of
something that i can imagine in an
alternative universe what would have
happened if i if i've gone into physics
um
i try to think that like well depends on
what your
path ends up being but that it's it's
not
super important right like exactly what
you decide to
major on like i think there's there's
um
i think tim urban like the blogger had a
good visualization of this where it's
like you know like he
he has a picture where you have all
sorts of paths that he could pursue in
your life and then maybe you're in the
middle of it and so there's maybe some
paths that are not accessible to you but
like the tree that is still in front of
you
gives you a lot of optionality and so um
there's two lessons to learn from that
like we have a huge number of options
now
and probably you're just one
to reflect
like to try to uh derive wisdom from the
one little path you've taken so far may
be flawed because there's all these
other paths you could have taken yeah so
it's like
uh so one it's inspiring that you can
take any path now and two
it's like you you the path you've taken
so far is just one of many possible ones
but it does seem that like
physics and computer science both open a
lot of doors in a lot of different doors
it's very interesting it is i i like in
this case like and especially in in our
case because i could see the difference
i studied i
i did i went to college in europe and uh
went to college here in the us so i
could see the differences like in the
european system is
um more rigid in the sense that when you
decide to study physics you don't have a
lot especially in the early years you
don't have a lot of um you can't choose
to take like a class from like computer
science course or something like that
you don't have a lot of freedom to
explore in that sense in university as
opposed to here in the us where you have
more freedom and i think um
i think that's important i think that's
what constitutes you know a good kind of
educational system is one that
gravitates towards the interests of a
student as as you progress but i think
in order for you to do that you need to
explore different areas and i i felt
like if i had a chance to take say more
computer science class when i was in
college i would have probably
have taken those classes but um yeah but
i ended up like focusing maybe too
too much in physics and i think you're
at least
my perception is that you can explore
more more
fields but there is a kind of it's funny
but physics can be difficult
so i don't see too many computer science
people than
exploring into physics it's only like
the one
the not the one but one of the
beneficial things of physics it feels
like it
uh
what was it rutherford that said like
like basically that physics is the hard
thing and everything is easy uh so like
there's a certain sense once you've
figured out some basic like physics
that it's not that you need the tools of
physics to understand the other
disciplines it's that you're empowered
by having done difficult [ __ ] i mean the
ultimate i think is probably mathematics
there yeah true
uh so maybe just doing difficult things
and proving to yourself that you can do
difficult things whatever those are
that's not positive i believe not
positive yeah and i think like i i
before i started a company i had like i
worked in
the financial sector for a bit and like
i think having a physics background i
was i felt i was not afraid of like
learning like finance things and i think
like when you come from those
backgrounds you are generally not afraid
of stepping into other fields and
learning about those because
um yeah i feel they've learned a lot of
difficult things and um
yeah that's an added benefit i believe
this was an incredible conversation luis
joao
we started with uh who do we start with
feynman ended up with messi and ronaldo
so this is like the perfect conversation
it's really an honor that you guys would
waste all this time with me today it's
it was really fun thanks thank you so
much for having us yeah thank you so
much
thanks for listening to this
conversation with louise and joe
albertalla and thank you to skiff simply
safe indeed netsuite and for sigmatic
check them out in the description to
support this podcast
and now let me leave you with some words
from richard feynman nobody ever figures
out what life is all about
and it doesn't matter explore the world
nearly everything is really interesting
if you go into it deeply enough
thank you for listening i hope to see
you next time
you